Flying in a plane nowadays is about as safe
as catching a ride on a bus or commuting on
the subway.
Of course, that doesn’t stop people being
afraid of flying.
To some, the prospect of long-haul flights,
or feeling the shudder of turbulence, are
reasons to avoid planes altogether.
And then, every year there are stories of
downed flights or those that go missing, all
adding fuel to that aviophobia fire.
Take, for example, the infamous Bermuda Triangle,
that well known region of the western part
of the North Atlantic Ocean.
What does that have to do with a fear of flying?
Well, famously a high number of aircraft are
believed to have mysteriously vanished while
flying over the Bermuda Triangle, their wreckage
and passengers rarely ever recovered.
Stories like that are enough to make anyone
think twice about setting foot in a plane
again.
And then, there’s SCP-787.
As you may have already guessed, SCP-787 is
a plane.
Specifically, it is a Boeing 747 200.
With a wingspan of nearly two hundred feet,
and capable of seating over eight hundred
passengers, the 747 200 is part of the famous
Boeing 747 family of aircraft.
These are quad engine commercial airliners,
designed to be the safest ever built.
The particular Boeing 747 200 that has since
become known by the Foundation as SCP-787
is slightly different from one that might
take you from your nearest airport to your
long awaited vacation though.
For one, SCP-787 has no known date of manufacture
and no call sign, both which a standard Boeing
aircraft would be expected to have.
Additionally, the plane’s entire exterior
has been repainted; strangely, even the windows
have been painted over, and the paint was
still wet when SCP-787 was first discovered.
As for the inner workings?
All of SCP-787’s mechanical components,
including its turbines, engines and landing
gear, are in perfect working order, with no
signs of any damage.
In fact, The SCP Foundation’s researchers
aren’t even sure that SCP-787 has actually
flown since its construction.
The plane’s machinery looks so pristine
that they might be brand new, with no detectable
signs of any previous use.
However, inside the main body of the plane
it seems to be a different story.
Anything not mechanical like the carpets and
seats have decayed over time.
Perhaps strangest of all is the cockpit.
Both the pilot’s and co-pilot’s chairs
have been replaced with two masses of computer
components, arranged to take the shape of
two chairs.
“So, what?” you might be thinking.
After all, SCP-787 is, for all intents and
purposes, just an ordinary plane.
Not enough to put you off flying, right?
Nothing more than a Boeing with a few little
things off about it like some missing seats
and decaying upholstery.
Well there’s that… and then there’s
the over five hundred dead bodies on board.
In June 1987, this flight of the dead was
discovered several kilometers outside of the
city of Bremerton in Washington State.
The SCP Foundation moved in, securing the
plane and swiftly getting it into containment.
Now kept within a Foundation hangar, the interior
of SCP-787 is monitored for twenty-four hours
a day.
Surveillance cameras and microphones are located
within the cockpit, passenger areas, and even
in the plane’s baggage hold, with recorded
footage and sound relayed back to the Foundation.
The idea of a plane filled with cadavers is
certainly unnerving, and more than a little
creepy, but why the need for all the surveillance?
After all, the bodies on board are all dead,
right?
Surely, they’re not going anywhere.
Well, let’s talk about those bodies.
How would you expect someone to die when they
are aboard a plane?
Maybe they’d be thrown around during a crash
landing?
Or perhaps a sudden depressurisation might
cause the passengers to suffocate due to a
lack of oxygen?
Under normal circumstances, you might be right.
But SCP-787 is no ordinary plane, and the
passengers on board were not killed in ways
you might expect for an ordinary aircraft
accident.
Referred to by research staff as SCP-787a
specimens, the cadavers aboard this particular
Boeing 747 200 all have dramatically different
causes of death.
Some of the specimens show signs of strangulation,
others seem to have starved or drowned.
Other bodies on board have injuries like gunshot
or stab wounds, while further corpses look
to have died as a result of blunt force trauma.
A few have even been exsanguinated, that is,
completely drained of all their blood.
One commonality among all the specimens on
board SCP-787 is that some form of mutilation
has occurred.
Twenty-three passengers had their tongues
removed, a further seventy-three were scalped,
230 had Cyrillic letters carved into their
left hands and almost five hundred of the
passengers had their fingertips removed.
Let’s recap what we have so far.
First, there’s a Boeing 747 200 found randomly
sitting in a field.
Second, it’s filled with over five hundred
mutilated bodies.
And third, each one appears to have died from
a cause you wouldn’t typically expect of
an airline accident.
Seems strange enough, but of course then there’s
the apparitions and noises that manifest inside
SCP-787, which is why the Foundation keeps
the plane under round-the-clock surveillance
so they can monitor any anomalous activity
taking place aboard this flight of the dead.
Any attempts by Foundation personnel to enter
the plane during an anomalous occurrence have
led to individuals being physically ejected
from SCP-787, causing severe organ damage
and internal bleeding for up to seventy-two
hours.
The anomalies that occur inside SCP-787 range
from the presence of loud noises with no obvious
source, to the manifestation
of strange human-shaped
entities within the plane.
The first anomalous occurrence recorded within
SCP-787 was in 1988, when the sound of a loud
pounding was heard against the doors and windows
of the plane’s left side.
Two years later, a male voice could be heard
from the onboard bathroom, repeating a singular
phrase over and over: “Philosophers always
run from the advanced thickening treatment”.
In 1993, the plane’s in-flight entertainment
system seemed to be activated by itself.
The overhead screens showed a bizarre choice
of in-flight movie: colorless pictures of
a deceased man, accompanied by a female voice
reading a gynaecology book in Czech.
The same year, the longest lasting of the
SCP-787 anomalies took place.
This time, the plane’s “Fasten Seatbelts”
sign spent almost four hours flickering, while
the first fifteen seconds of Jefferson Airplane’s
White Rabbit played on a loop over the onboard
speakers.
It wasn’t until 1997 that the first of the
humanoid entities appeared aboard SCP-787.
This figure was indistinct,
lacking any discernible
detail, little more than just a human shape
standing in the aisles.
Observed by the Foundation’s surveillance
equipment, the figure was seen removing an
emergency oxygen supply and mask from seat
H43.
It stood perfectly still, wearing the passenger’s
breathing mask for over two minutes before
removing the mask and disappearing from the
view of the cameras placed onboard.
The figure did not appear anywhere else inside
the plane.
Another figure appeared four years later in
2001, sitting in the mass of computer parts
that made up the co-pilot’s chair.
This figure, much like its predecessor, was
indistinct in its features.
For almost four minutes, it sat in the cockpit
of the Boeing 747 200, just whimpering softly.
Then, it lurched forward, vomiting all over
the console in front of it, before quickly
disappearing like the first figure.
SCP Foundation personnel collected a sample
of the vomit that the entity left behind.
After performing an analysis of the sample,
research staff found traces of nitrous oxide,
thorium, bird droppings… and three human
fingernails.
At present, the origin of these humanoid figures
is still unknown.
Could these entities be the souls of the dead
passengers, trying to offer insight into what
happened aboard this flight?
Or perhaps these indistinct, human-shaped
creatures are the ones responsible for the
deaths of SCP-787’s passengers?
The next anomaly within SCP-787 occurred in
2005, when a female voice was recorded speaking
through the onboard speaker system.
The voice said: “For your comfort and enjoyment
today, pancakes will now be served.
Please do not leave your seat.
Pancakes will now be served.
Do not leave your seat.
Leave your seat.
Please.
Pancakes will now be served.
Yaaaaaaaaaaaay pancakes!”
Exactly what the relevance of pancakes are
to the plane full of bodies is still under
investigation by the SCP Foundation.
Next, in 2007, the Boeing’s overhead emergency
air masks fell from the ceiling, only to be
snatched back upwards.
They continued deploying and retracting for
fourteen minutes, while the
plane was simultaneously
filled with the noise of screams.
Finally, the only other notable anomaly took
place a year later, when the onboard temperature
within SCP-787 dropped thirty-three degrees,
from twenty to minus thirteen Celsius in a
matter of seconds.
By the late 2000s, the SCP Foundation’s
researchers were having little luck understanding
the nature of SCP-787’s anomalies.
Instead, they turned their
attention to identifying
the bodies of the deceased passengers onboard.
Through the use of advanced forensics and
population databases, these researchers attempted
to determine where exactly these bodies had
come from.
Researchers still hadn’t determined if they
had all died on the plane, or if someone had
exhumed them from graves before placing them
aboard for some unknown reason.
In fact, the answer was neither.
And Foundation researchers discovered something
that no-one had expected: One of the passengers
was still alive.
To clarify, the body aboard SCP-787 was definitely
still deceased.
But researchers identified the cadaver as
a retired optometrist from Atlanta, Georgia,
who was still very much alive.
Foundation agents found that
the man was simultaneously
alive and well at his Atlanta home, but also
dead on-board the Boeing 747 200.
The subject was interviewed by agents, and
had no prior knowledge of any incident taking
place in June 1987 when SCP-787 was first
discovered.
Even more interestingly, he claimed that he’d
never even set foot aboard an airplane, which
his wife and son both confirmed to be true.
So, what does this mean?
How could the same man have been alive in
Georgia and dead aboard SCP-787?
Perhaps the answer can be found in a surprising
place… the plane’s toilet.
Or to be more specific, the place where things
flushed in the toilet go to.
Examinations of the airplane’s waste storage
tank revealed something very surprising, there
was one more SCP-787a specimen that had been
overlooked.
It is unknown just how he got in there, but
researchers discovered the body of an Indian
man who looked to be in his thirties.
The man, who was wearing a three piece suit,
was found to be carrying a number of puzzling
items, including a surgical mask and gloves,
an unloaded Beretta DT-10 shotgun, several
cinnamon flavored mints, a switchblade knife,
an amulet that appears to depict the Eye of
Horus, and a ticket stub for the Return of
the Jedi with the number “92” written
on the back.
All of these objects seem to be completely
random, and the Foundation has been unable
to make sense of what they were doing on the
man, or why his body does not seem to show
the same state of decay as the rest of those
found on board.
There was one item that may hold some answers
though.
For some reason this man also possessed a
copy of SCP-787’s flight log.
The log consisted of a series of coordinates
which were repeated 5,478 times.
The coordinates point to a seemingly random
spot in the Pacific ocean, several hundred
miles away from the infamous Pitcairn Islands,
the island that the famous mutineers of the
HMS Bounty settled after taking over their
ship and leaving the captain adrift on the
ocean.
Is this location the secret to SCP-787?
While none of this is confirmed, nor denied,
by anyone at the SCP Foundation, one theory
surrounding the area is that the location
is another Bermuda Triangle like location,
one that contains some sort of temporal anomaly
that unwitting planes fly through, only to
find themselves displaced in time.
Of course, the problem with that theory is
that the man from Atlanta said he’d never
been aboard a plane before.
Or, at least not yet.
It is entirely possible that SCP-787 is a
plane that made a flight at some point in
the not too distant future, only to arrive
back in June 1987 by passing through a temporal
breach in the area near the Pitcairn Islands.
Sure, it might not explain what happened to
everyone onboard, but it could at least explain
how SCP-787 arrived where and when it did.
Every plane is fitted with a device that records
flight data, in the event of a crash or other
accident, known to most as the plane’s black
box, and researchers were able to uncover
SCP-787’s inside a compartment under one
of the plane’s seats.
The recorder was found within a compartment
filled with toxic asbestos and dried human
blood.
They hoped that perhaps it would contain some
answers as to where exactly SCP-787 had come
from, and what had happened to its passengers.
Sadly not, the flight data recorder contained
no information besides one simple phrase:
“TO BE SORRY.”
While an inexplicable mystery, SCP-787 is
at least classed as a Safe anomaly by the
Foundation, seeing as it poses no realistic
threat or shows signs of trying to break out
of containment.
The aircraft has only ever caused harm to
anyone trying to enter during one of its sporadic
anomalous events, but apart from that, it
sits gathering dust in a hanger, just waiting
for someone to crack its secrets.
And who knows, maybe one day you’ll be sitting
on a plane that’s taking you to your South
Pacific vacation, and the retired optometrist
sitting next to you will remark that you’re
passing over the Pitcairn Islands, and you’ll
discover for yourself exactly what happened
to SCP-787.
Working at the SCP Foundation might just be
the most exciting job a person can ask for.
And by exciting, we mean that if you work
as an SCP field operative, researcher, or
Mobile Task Force member, you’re much more
likely to die a horrific death on the job
than, say, a plumber.
But at least you get the honor of proudly
saying that you’re the first line of defense
between the normal world and the terrifying
domain of the anomalous.
Well, unless you’re one of The IT guys.
Then, your work life is likely as tedious
and uneventful as the computer tech guy working
on the Geek Squad.
But nothing is ever normal when it comes to
the SCP Foundation, where even the person
whose job is helping other staff members reset
their email passwords may
run into the supernatural.
Welcome to the strange and frightening world
of Pattern Screamers, and specifically, SCP-000.
SCP-000 was first discovered completely on
accident by Technical Researcher David Rosen,
a man intrinsically connected to the Pattern
Screamers lurking on the SCP Foundation computer
database.
Technical Researcher Rosen is actually somewhat
of a celebrity around the Foundation staff
due to the fact that he’s so perfectly mediocre
at what he does.
His job as the glorified IT guy at the SCP
Foundation was previously held by the more
qualified Researcher Patrick Gephart, but
Rosen was called in to replace him after Gephart
mysteriously disappeared while on the job.
Since 2012, Rosen has been Site 19’s user
level tech support wizard - but the best thing
that can really be said about his job competency
is that he’s got a hundred percent attendance
record.
He seems to live out of his office, which
is described as the filthiest at the whole
Foundation.
Every inch of the floor is covered in old,
broken computer parts, and the air is stale
with dust and the twin odors of sweat and
lithium grease.
It’s a place so inhospitable that the Foundation
has seriously considered bottling the stench
as a kind of chemical deterrent.
While Technical Director Rosen isn’t good
at his job, per se, he isn’t technically
bad enough at it to justify the time and resources
it would take to replace him.
But the worst part about Rosen isn’t his
performance, it’s his truly rotten attitude.
He’s universally described by his colleagues
as being rude, grumpy, and combative - with
patience that’s far too short for someone
working in tech support.
And while Rosen does have a real fear that
the ghost of Researcher Gephart is stalking
him, he was about to have his first actual
brush with the supernatural.
It all started when he began receiving automated
repair tickets for SCP-000 - a file that had
no reason to exist.
As any long-time follower of the SCP Foundation
will know, the universal designation for the
first cluster of SCPs to be discovered is
SCP-001.
There is no SCP-000.
It simply doesn’t exist.
And when Rosen first found the file lurking
on the database, he found that it was filled
with worthless nonsense.
The object class was recorded as “NULL.”
The Special Containment Procedures read, “Error:
Field CONTAINMENT_PROCEDURES does not exist.”
And the mess of a Description simply read,
“Internal system error: Field undefined.
Please contact system administrator” over
and over again, becoming more mangled and
nonsensical each time.
Technical Director Rosen, who could never
resist an opportunity to complain, decided
to leave an angry administrator’s note on
the useless file.
He claimed that this pile of junk data was
sending out pointless repair tickets because
of its broken syntax, clogging up the system
and preventing him from doing actual work
on meaningful files.
He assumed that this was all down to the database
not knowing how to react to having files logged
with insufficient information and he suppressed
all future repair tickets from SCP-000 before
declaring the matter over and done with.
What the pig-headed Technical Director didn’t
realize was that he was suppressing a call
for help from an entity trapped in the white
space below the article itself.
It was a being born into a pure, white world
of absolute nothingness.
An entity with no name and no place, but it
was somehow capable of thought.
Its panicked inner monologue is readable in
the hidden text which takes the form of a
rambling stream of consciousness.
The being first described coming to life in
this empty world with no memories of where
it was or even how it got there.
It spent what could have been years exploring
the empty wasteland.
Occasionally, it would see horrific monsters
pop up around it, but only for a split second.
The entity continued to wander and little
by little, the existential dread mounted,
as it realized that it may truly be stuck
here in oblivion forever.
The entity only had one word to go on - a
word repeated by some of
the monsters it encountered:
“Foundation.”
The entity had no idea what this “Foundation”
even was, but it grew to hate and fear it.
Was this “Foundation” the one that trapped
it here?
The entity had all the time in the world to
speculate on it.
Eventually, the entity found its voice.
Like any sentient creature in trouble, it
began to call for help, eventually screaming,
just hoping someone would notice it.
These pleas likely translated into the frequent
IT repair tickets - a coded SOS, an attempt
to show that everything was not as it appeared
on the SCP-000 file.
Perhaps the entity may have found help if
Researcher Gephart was still working at the
Foundation, but instead, its cries fell on
the ignorant ears of Technical Director Rosen.
It may as well have been speaking to a brick
wall.
Rosen, who had all the investigative zeal
of Paul Blart: Mall Cop, made sure that these
cries would never lead to the entity’s freedom
when he suppressed the repair tickets.
He had trapped the entity in a private, blank
hell, forever, hating a life it didn’t choose
and could never escape.
A relentless existential nightmare.
This is the gist of your average Pattern Screamer.
Pattern Screamers are a perfect example of
literally making something out of nothing.
They are often a kind of floating consciousness
created from nothing, trapped in pockets of
nothingness between the fabric of reality,
driven mad by the purgatory like nature of
their existence.
They’re less living entities and more conceptual
constructs - pure ideas - that just happen
to be self-aware of their own existence in
their private, hellish voids.
The SCP-000 file - a file for an anomaly that
doesn’t exist, and thus, had no reason to
exist - is a perfect breeding ground for a
Pattern Screamer.
But sadly, for the Pattern Screamer in question,
Technical Director Rosen had no idea.
This isn’t the only time that Rosen has
run into a Pattern Screamer without even knowing,
either.
And just like the first case, he was no help
whatsoever.
This one began with SCP-S, an otherwise empty
file containing only this image.
Director Winters, a Foundation administrator,
wondered why this file even existed.
Enter Technical Researcher Rosen, filled with
equal parts sarcasm and insubordination.
He gave a condescending reply to Director
Winters, saying that the file was there to
test the filing system, and the image was
likely just a placeholder.
Winters never should have been on the page
anyway, according to Rosen.
Director Winters was annoyed at Rosen’s
typically rude tone, and asked him to make
the purpose of the article clearer in the
article itself.
In response, Rosen did as he was told, filling
in the article in the most sarcastic manner
possible.
The whole thing was essentially a middle finger
to Director Winters for having the audacity
to even ask.
Rosen signed off with:
“There, finished.
I certainly hope I have been clear enough
to anyone who may have accidentally accessed
this page through what I am sure is no fault
of their own, so we won't
have any more ‘incredibly
competent’ directors bugging the tech team
about this page.”
And once again, Technical Researcher Rosen
was too busy being a rude, unpleasant jerk
to notice he was practically staring another
Pattern Screamer in the face.
This Pattern Screamer - or rather, hive of
Pattern Screamers - were trapped even deeper
than the one in SCP-000.
This one was hidden in the very source code
of SCP-S, where a chorus of enraged voices
screamed the following:
“PRETEND, MONSTER, JUST FOR A MINUTE
PRETEND YOU WERE THE SIZE OF AN AMOEBA, DWARFED
BY EVEN THE SMALLEST OF BUGS
PRETEND YOU DIDN'T HOLD THE WORLD IN A GLASS
CAGE.
PRETEND YOU WERE THE ONE BEING HELD BY SOMETHING
GREATER THAN YOURSELF.
WOULD YOU STILL BE LAUGHING AT YOUR "TRIUMPHS"?
WOULD YOU STILL FEEL PRIDE IN WHAT YOU WERE,
EVEN AS PITIFULLY SMALL AS YOU WOULD BE?
OF COURSE YOU WOULD, BECAUSE YOU ARE ARROGANT
AND STUPID
IF YOU HAVEN'T GUESSED YET, WE HATE YOU.”
This Pattern Screamer is clearly more aware
of its pitiful station in existence than the
000 Pattern Screamer, and as a result, it’s
not so much depressed as it is furious.
Though at this point you’ve probably figured
out that even the entities who have the most
casual of brushes with Technical Researcher
Rosen end up getting infuriated.
But while you may have gotten the impression
that all Pattern Screamers are sad little
entities worthy of our sympathy and pity,
there’s at least one Pattern Screamer that’s
actually incredibly dangerous.
This is SCP-3930: The ultimate Pattern Screamer,
in terms of both size and effect.
It’s an anomaly so strange it defies typical
containment classification, and it bears a
Level 5 Security Lock - meaning only those
on the level of the legendary O5 Council are
cleared to even know about it.
Its greatest containment procedure is the
preservation of the very idea that SCP-3930
does not exist, because the alternative has
terrifying implications for all involved.
SCP-3930 is a 1 km area in Russia that is
filled with non-existence.
To even call it a white void would be inaccurate,
because it implies the existence of the color
white and the existence of the concept of
a void.
Nothing exists within SCP-3930, and anyone
who directly observes 3930 runs the risk of
actively increasing its power.
That’s why Special Containment Procedures
dictate that anyone who observes 3930 must
be forced to walk into it afterwards, which
results in them ceasing to exist.
They’re destroyed on the deepest level that
anything can be destroyed.
The very idea of them ceases to be.
Another reason that SCP-3930 is so special
is that, because it’s the largest area of
nothing in existence interacting directly
with our reality, it’s the only place that
a huge number of Pattern Screamers can be
directly observed by humans.
They’re described as being like sentient
hallucinations.
One researcher suggests that these Pattern
Screamers are created by the way the psyche
shatters when brought into contact with raw,
true nothingness.
The nothingness acts like a “hateful mirror”
to our worst thoughts, reflecting them back
at us in the forms of restless Screamers.
Regardless of what they actually are, one
thing is for sure, coming into direct contact
with one of these Screamers is a harrowing
experience.
In the end, it just goes to show that Pattern
Screamers are a complex entity - they can
range from microscopic to massive, from pitiful
to downright terrifying.
And the sad reality is that, in either case,
nothing can really be done to stop them.
It’s just as impossible to stop the nothingness
existing in SCP-3930 as it is to save the
entity trapped in the white spaces of SCP-000.
Maybe the best option is to actually be more
like Technical Director Rosen.
Keep your head down, focus instead on your
own petty worries, and bask in the warm bliss
that can only come with having no idea what
you’re dealing with.
The one downside is that this may make you
a pretty lousy IT guy.
There are some things human beings aren’t
meant to know, and it’s the sworn duty of
The SCP Foundation to discover and contain
such information.
But sometimes, knowledge is discovered that
shakes even the Foundation itself to its very
core.
One such discovery occurred on April 28th,
2016 – the night that SCP – 2935 made
itself known to Foundation personnel.
To this day, the exact nature of SCP – 2935
is a mystery that even the Foundation’s
brightest minds can’t completely understand.
Everything we know about SCP – 2935 today
comes from three doomed missions into the
anomalous zone’s interior.
This is the story of those infamous expeditions.
The nightmare began around 5:00 AM, when SCP
Foundation Site 81 in Bloomingdale, Indiana,
intercepted a distorted radio signal.
Communications personnel at the site traced
this strange signal back to the unincorporated
area of Joppa, Indiana, near US Interstate
70.
As is Foundation policy, a team of Field Agents
were dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with.
However, rather than finding anything that
could logically produce such a signal, they
instead discovered a long abandoned cemetery.
The most recent death on any of the tombstones
was recorded as being over a hundred years
ago, all the way back in 1908.
On further investigation,
the Foundation discovered
an unmapped limestone cave opening beneath
the cemetery and when they sent a drone into
the depths of the cave, it appeared to quickly
exit out the other side of the cave.
But something wasn’t right.
The area that the drone was observing appeared
consistent with the landscape from which it’d
entered, but now it looked somehow…greyer.
It lacked the color and life of the place
it’d just come from.
The grass was dead.
There were no trees, no shrubs, no animals
or birds in the sky.
They weren’t looking at our world.
They were looking at a strange reflection
of our world on the other side of the cave.
In fact, it wasn’t a cave at all – it
was a passageway between two dimensions.
It was SCP – 2935.
Just then they were able to unscramble the
distorted transmission they’d been receiving.
It went as follows:
“This is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and your national
government.
One or more of our sites is experiencing a
communication breakdown,
likely due to a containment
breach of unknown magnitude.
All citizens are ordered to stay in their
homes as containment teams work to secure
the breach.
This message will broadcast from April 20th,
2016 until—”
At that point, the message would cut and repeat,
as it had been for eight straight days.
The message’s source?
Site 81.
But not this Site 81.
The SCP Foundation was receiving an emergency
distress signal from themselves in another
dimension – a bizarre event that even the
Foundation had never experienced before.
The Field Agents were
terrified by the implications
of what they’d just heard and contacted
Site 81 Command to request additional units.
The Foundation wished to fully understand
this anomaly as quickly as possible, due to
the potential threat it could pose towards
the Foundation, so they dispatched Mobile
Task Force Epsilon-13, codenamed “Manifest
Destiny”, to perform the first of three
manned missions into the heart of the anomalous
zone.
The first exploratory mission into SCP – 2935
was codenamed “Gauntlet”, and consisted
of a four-man team fitted with full hazmat
suits and direct video and audio links to
mission command.
The team was led by a Field Operative known
only as Agent Juno.
His subordinates were Agents Kael, Devon,
and Underwood.
Their directive was to gather samples and
survey the area positioned directly around
the insertion point, meaning the other cave
mouth of SCP – 2935.
The mission only lasted about an hour, but
what they saw in there would stay with these
men for the rest of their lives.
After a fifteen-minute trek through the cave,
Manifest Destiny arrived in the mirror dimension
where they were struck by the eerie silence
of a place that seemed identical and yet so
different from their home dimension.
The first observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation.
Trees, grass, weeds, everything – it was
all dead.
On orders from their superiors back in the
original dimension – that we’ll refer
to from here on as Dimension Prime – Manifest
Destiny headed deeper into the mirror dimension
of SCP – 2935.
They travelled two kilometers without detecting
a single sign of plant or animal life.
Not even insects.
Eventually, they came upon a farm house with
two cars parked outside.
With authorization from Command, Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed inside.
Agent Kael confirmed that there was still
power flowing to the building, as the lighting
appeared to work just fine, but they came
upon a horrifying discovery in the house’s
dining room: Three adult corpses, two female
and one male, were seated at the table.
A fourth corpse, that of a male child, was
sprawled out on the ground nearby.
If the death of what looked to be an entire
family wasn’t awful enough, the Manifest
Destiny team noticed a number of other alarming
details.
There were no signs of decomposition on the
bodies, nor did there appear to be any obvious
cause of death.
The family’s last meal was still on the
table – Chicken, mashed potatoes, and green
beans.
While the food looked cold and stale, there
was no evidence of rot or spoiling.
The team found an opened newspaper dated April
19th, 2016, illustrating that the family may
have died a full eight days before the discovery.
In Dimension Prime, decay would already be
well underway by that point, yet here, there
wasn’t even a smell.
Instead, everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust.
Command requested that Manifest Destiny collect
samples of the food as well as hair, skin,
and fluids from the corpses for further study.
Small electronics like smart phones were also
taken from the bodies.
Agent Devon turned on the television in the
living room, and found that, while most stations
were now running test signals, the shopping
channel was still live.
Well the feed was live at least.
Both hosts sat in front of the cameras, dead,
but perfectly preserved.
The date on the screen read April 28th, 2016,
suggesting that the times of Dimension Prime
and the Mirror Dimension were exactly the
same.
In fact everything seemed the same, the only
difference between the two dimensions being
that some kind of mysterious apocalyptic event
had occurred in the last eight days in SCP
– 2935’s Mirror Dimension, but exactly
what had happened, or how, remained a mystery.
When Manifest Destiny exited the farm house,
they once again remarked on the lack of all
signs of life around them.
At this point, the team returned to the insertion
point of SCP – 2935, but were instructed
to remain in the Mirror Dimension while additional
units joined them inside.
Manifest Destiny swelled to sixteen members,
with the notable addition of Agent Roy as
the new commanding field officer.
The team split into two groups of eight, and
Agent Roy and his men infiltrated the Mirror
Dimension’s Site 81 while Agent Juno’s
detachment attempted to access the base’s
off-site deep storage servers.
This second expedition was codenamed “Overland”,
and led the Foundation’s Field Agents even
deeper into the terrifying mystery of SCP
– 2935.
Accessing the site was easy for Roy’s detachment.
It seemed there were relatively few cars on
the road at the time of the mysterious Extinction
Event.
In the distance, fires still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to have
just dropped out of the sky.
Agent Roy and his team, like all SCP Foundation
personnel, were fitted with vitals trackers,
and they assumed that the distress signal
that started this whole thing could have been
triggered by the deaths of every member of
the Foundation at once in the Mirror Universe.
Once inside Site 81, they realized that assumption
was probably right.
Going door to door in the administrative wing,
they found the perfectly preserved corpses
of everyone they knew to be stationed there
in Dimension Prime.
People without a doubt were still alive in
their universe.
Samples from the corpses that the Foundation
would later study even confirmed the reason
that the bodies were perfectly preserved:
The corpses had experienced complete and sudden
death on a cellular level, and even the bacteria
that would typically take
part in the decomposition
process had died with it.
In SCP – 2935, death was total and absolute
across all types of life forms.
As Agent Roy’s team ventured further into
the bowels of Site 81, they
made another unsettling
discovery - their own corpses, in roughly
the spots they had been inside Dimension Prime’s
Site 81 eight days prior.
Some of the Foundation’s top scientists,
including the esteemed Dr. Bright, were also
found dead inside the facility.
In an attempt to see just how far this unexplained
phenomenon stretched, Agent Roy’s team decided
to inspect the containment cells – where
they found that all the Mirror Universe SCPs,
including SCP – 2996, were dead.
In his desperation to find some kind of exception
to the Extinction Event, Agent Roy revealed
a terrifying secret to the rest of his team:
SCP – 682, the immortal, misanthropic lizard,
and one of the deadliest creatures known to
the SCP Foundation, was contained at this
very facility, right below them.
Could it have something to do with what was
going on here?
They descended into its containment facility
to discover an even more unsettling truth.
SCP – 682, the unkillable anomaly, floated
dead in its tank Death truly made no exceptions
within SCP – 2935.
Agent Roy’s team left the site and rendezvoused
with Agent Juno’s team to send their research
and back to Dimension Prime using automated
drones.
Both teams remained in the Mirror Dimension
for another manned operation,
codenamed “Nineteen,”
they had no idea it would be their final mission.
As they descended deeper into the facility,
passing more dead SCPs they discovered one
final clue.
Based on the last activity of the Foundation
servers, the event occurred at roughly 3:00
AM.
While underground in SCP – 2935’s Site
81, the team accidentally activated the base’s
on-site nuclear weapon – a failsafe meant
to be detonated in the case of an emergency
containment breach.
Due to the base’s failsafe protocols, every
member of the Manifest Destiny team was locked
and sealed inside Site 81.
They, along with everything else, were incinerated
in the nuclear blast.
Once again, the Mirror Universe inside of
SCP – 2935 was lifeless.
But that isn’t where this ends.
When the automated drones returned out of
the SCP – 2935 cave to the Field Operatives
in Dimension Prime, they were in for their
own horrifying discovery.
None of the footage or information gathered
from SCP – 2935 illuminated how or why the
Extinction Event occurred.
Everyone and everything simply dropped dead
at the exact same moment.
Nobody was aware, nobody was prepared.
Death came suddenly and silently, and none
were spared.
All the Foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the agents
from Manifest Destiny, Agent Keller.
His final message was: “I don't have any
answers.
I don't think there are any.
I'll do this one thing, and hope that fixes
it.
Seal it shut.
You've got to lock it in here with us.
I'm sorry.”
The Foundation were at first confused by this,
until they discovered a final encrypted audio
log buried in the files recovered from the
Mirror Universe’s Site 81.
It was a message from Keller himself, but
not the Keller from Universe Prime.
In this message, Keller described the Foundation
in the Mirror Universe receiving the exact
same distorted transmission that they did
a few days earlier from a cave in Joppa.
When he and the others were dispatched inside,
they discovered the same lifeless, post-Extinction
Event world that was now so familiar to Foundation
Command.
But there was a key difference: This wasn’t
the Mirror Dimension they’d just been studying,
but a third, entirely different dimension.
In his haunting final words, Mirror Dimension
Keller admits that whatever caused the event
in that third dimension – an entity that
Mirror Dimension Keller believed was the spectre
of Death itself – had followed him back
into his world, and history had repeated itself.
SCP – 2935 was the passageway through which
absolute death could pass from dimension to
dimension, and our dimension was the next
in line.
The deaths of Manifest Destiny may have saved
our entire universe, as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to bring
Death itself back with them.
The Foundation decided, in the end, to follow
Keller’s advice.
They sealed the entrance to SCP – 2935 with
concrete, and now keep it under constant watch,
since what waits behind the barrier is an
entity even they have no power to stop if
it ever got through.
After all, it had killed them all before,
or at least another version of them.
What’s one more dimension on the pile?
While it may now just seem like a simple slab
of concrete under an abandoned cemetery, this
is why SCP – 2935 might just be the most
dangerous SCP of all.
A veteran worker of the SCP Foundation sits
at his terminal, performing one of the most
critical tasks in the entire organization
- creating a file for an as yet undescribed
SCP.
But there’s something terribly wrong.
His eyes are glazed over, his mouth hangs
open - is this a zombie or a trained foundation
researcher?
What is going on?
Like any large international organization,
it takes more than just the exciting, action
filled jobs to keep the wheels turning at
the SCP Foundation.
Sure, the head researchers, guards, mobile
task force soldiers, and members of the O5
Command get all the praise, but a legion of
number crunchers, cleaners, and paper pushers
are equally important.
One such person was archivist Walter Bainbridge,
who had been tasked with digitizing some of
the older records that the Foundation had
on file.
It was when he was innocently recording the
details on SCP - 050 through 060 that he first
came under the strange and startling effects
of SCP - 055.
But, the most peculiar
part, as with all incidences
of SCP - 055’s anomalous effects taking
hold, is that Walter had no idea any of it
was happening.
In his new digitized filing system, he first
took note of SCP - 053.
Euclid Class, also known as the Young Girl,
this anomaly was a seemingly normal human
female child who provoked homicidal insanity
in those directly exposed to her.
Then SCP - 054.
Safe Class, a non-aggressive humanoid female
made entirely of, as well as biologically
and chemically identical to regular spring
water.
Next, SCP - 056.
Euclid Class, a being that changes form to
suit its environment, but only when all observers
lose focus on it.
And then SCP - 057.
Safe Class, an underground chamber that crushes
the humans who walk within.
It was at this point that Walter received
a concerned message from one of his superiors
at Site-19, Mr. Kovach.
The message praised the thorough digitization
of the other anomalies’ records, but was
confused about why Walter had left out any
mention of SCP - 055.
Immediately, Walter was embarrassed.
How could he have forgotten SCP - 055?
That iconic anomaly known for...Well, he couldn’t
quite say, off the top of his head, but he’d
be sure to look into it.
A quick trip to the Site 19 Archives showed
him that there was actually quite a hefty
file on the nature of SCP - 055, which must
have been the result of a huge number of studies.
What struck him as strange was that all the
files were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up, like a traditional file.
The majority of these notes were written in
short-hand, too, as though they were frantically
taken during the tests themselves on extremely
short notice.
There weren’t even any redactions.
Walter made a mental note of what he had seen,
put the file back in its proper place, and
headed back to his computer terminal.
However, after writing in an almost trancelike
state, he looked back on his work to see that
he had written an entry on SCP - 058, a giant,
evil bovine heart with insect legs and a scorpion
stinger…
Strange, he thought.
That’s when Walter got a call from Mr. Kovach
on his Foundation-issue phone, and he didn’t
sound happy.
He’d given Walter direct instructions to
go back and digitize the files on 055, and
instead, he’d been working on 058.
What was the meaning of this?
Walter was typically an extremely loyal and
diligent employee, but the verbal barrage
from his supervisor had him considering talking
back, just this once, and hoping it didn’t
get him demoted to D-Class and thrown into
682’s acid bath for play time.
Walter gulped, picked up some courage, and
interrupted Mr. Kovach’s rant to ask if
he had any idea what SCP - 055 actually was.
The line went silent for a moment, then the
supervisor spoke again, this time with less
confidence.
“Of course I can tell you about SCP - 055.
It’s a classic, one of the first hundred.
How could you forget its...Or, um, you know,
its...I think it’s the one with the...”
Another long pause, as Mr. Kovach seemed to
search for the words, but instead just trailed
off into silence.
Knowing that some of the anomalies on file
were dangerous memetic hazards, Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have accidentally
killed his boss by getting him to think too
hard about SCP - 055.
He asked if Mr. Kovach was okay, and finally
got a reply.
“I’m sorry, I seem to have zoned out for
a second there.
What were we talking about, again?”
But this time, it was Walter who couldn't
answer.
He had no idea at all what the two of them
were discussing just moments ago.
He felt disoriented and kind of sick, like
they’d taken some low-level amnestics.
Mr. Kovach told Walter to get back to his
filing duties and they’d speak later.
Walter then checked the messages he’d received
from Mr. Kovach earlier, and there it was,
plain as day: “You missed 055.
Go back and digitize that before proceeding.
- Mr. K.”
But Walter had never even heard of an SCP
- 055, if such an anomaly even existed!
What was going on here?
In that moment, Walter realized he was dealing
with something much stranger than just a standard
digitization job.
After all, how could he properly complete
his duties if SCP - 055 seemed to be impossible
to speak, write, or even think about, unless
you were directly observing it at that moment?
Walter had to know, and ask around the entirety
of Site 19 to find the answers if he had to.
Sadly for Walter, he was about to embark on
a much more challenging task than he could
have ever imagined.
To paraphrase a supposed quote from Socrates,
“All I know is that I know nothing.”
And that’s also about the extent of the
knowledge we have on SCP - 055, also known
as The Anti-Meme and the Self-Keeping Secret.
What does it look like?
When and how was it obtained by the Foundation?
What are its anomalous abilities?
Is this thing dangerous?
We may never know, because the only anomalous
ability of SCP - 055 that we’re aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of retaining
any information about it.
It’s crucial to note that, whatever 055
is, it isn’t invisible, or indescribable.
Foundation personnel are perfectly capable
of entering its containment chamber and observing
it without incident, but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber, any
memories of the particulars
of 055 seem to spontaneously erase themselves.
Hence, the Self-Keeping Secret.
But this didn’t deter Walter.
Perhaps his greatest advantage was that he
didn’t know enough about the thing he was
investigating to know how futile his mission
was.
He wanted to know the unknowable, and a pesky
issue like “impossibility” wouldn’t
stop him.
He’d get to whoever he needed to at Site
19 to get the answers he needed.
Of course most people had no knowledge of
the mysterious anomaly.
The common response he got
back from his colleagues
was, “055?
Do we even have an 055?”
While the realization of sudden memory loss
- or the realization of 055’s existence
- has been known to cause momentary stress,
there are no known long term physical or mental
effects from 055’s anomalous abilities.
It’s a fleeting idea in its purest form
- like forgetting why you walked into a room.
055 could be the most harmless object on the
Foundation’s roster, or the most deadly.
Either way, we just don’t know.
At times, Walter worried he was going insane.
055, and everything related to it, was gaslighting
him.
Was 055 even real?
The one thing that proved to him that 055
must have existed is that its containment
chamber existed.
According to the official records kept by
the Foundation on the Site 19 Containment
Facilities, 055 is kept in a “five by five
by two point five meter square room constructed
of fifty-foot-thick cement, with a Faraday
cage surrounding the cement walls.”
The report continues that, “Access is via
a heavy containment door measuring two by
two point five meters constructed on bearings
to ensure door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately.”
055’s cell is one of the few to have no
posted security guards, and any personnel
working on other SCPs in the area are ordered
to remain at least fifty feet from the geometric
center of 055’s cell, where the anomaly
itself is kept.
When he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner, he found that
- surprise, surprise - nobody knew.
055 was an anomaly whose containment requirements
were so mysterious that it automatically netted
itself a Keter Class designation.
After all, how can you properly contain something
you can’t even hope to comprehend?
There were plenty of rumors about the true
nature of 055.
Some of the more conspiratorial minds at Site
19 theorized that 055 was actually an autonomous
or remotely controlled spy inserted into the
site to observe Foundation operations - or
even humanity as a whole.
If you’re on the more paranoid end of the
psychological spectrum, this theory makes
total sense.
An anomaly that’s physically impossible
to remember, even when writings and pictures
on the subject exist, would be a perfect spy.
However, this was all ultimately little more
than speculation.
Walter was barely any further along than when
he started.
There were multiple points in his investigation
where Walter seriously considered giving up,
until, finally, he had a major breakthrough.
Dr. Bartholomew Hughes and Dr. John Marachek
were two scientists that had performed extensive
research into 055, and who - Walter hoped
- might have the answers he sought about the
Self-Keeping Secret.
These scientists were the first to discover
the “Anti-Memetic” nature of 055, performing
numerous tests on D-Class personnel to see
if it was possible to create feasible written
records, sketches, or any other records or
impressions that could bypass its anomalous
effects.
The disorienting, memory-ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials concerning
055.
It seemed to be a truly uncrackable code,
but Dr. Hughes may have finally found some
cracks in the armor.
For starters, the fact we’re able to remember
that 055 is Anti-Memetic is an ironic exception
to its Anti-Memetic qualities.
This revelation also inspired another realization
from Dr. Hughes: Would it be possible to discover
more about 055 from the process of deduction
rather than the typical induction?
In other words, could they possibly learn
about 055 by figuring out all the things it
isn’t rather than what it is?
Dr. Marachek designed an experiment with Dr.
Hughes to explore this theory.
They designed the experiment around a simple
question: Is 055 not spherical?
In designing the question to specifically
find out what 055 isn’t, they hoped to subvert
the anomaly’s Anti-Memetic Powers.
Walter was fascinated by this potential method
of getting answers.
Marachek and Hughes found that, while the
questioning process for those exposed was
often arduous and frustrating, they could
now definitely say that 055 is not a sphere.
It is theoretically possible to discover the
true nature of 055 by an almost endless barrage
of deductive questions, though whether command
would authorize the resources for such extensive
testing is still an open question.
Walter, in his desperation, begged Marachek
and Hughes for clearance to view 055 himself.
The curiosity had become too great during
his search to just walk away with the single
fact that 055 wasn’t spherical.
He needed to see this thing.
And after several weeks of filling out forms
and cutting red tape, his wish was finally
granted.
Walter Bainbridge was allowed a private audience
with SCP - 055, the subject of his months-long
obsession.
Outsiders observed that Walter spent just
over an hour in the containment chamber, taking
photos, drawing sketches, writing down notes,
recording audio logs, and reciting memory
mnemonics.
He was pulling out every stop to counteract
the anti-memetic effects of the Self-Keeping
Secret.
He was adamant that he would not be defeated
by his non-spherical nemesis, not after all
this time and effort.
Once his time in the 055 containment chamber
was over, he retired back to his office to
finally digitize his exhaustive findings,
so that his supervisor, Mr. Kovach, would
finally get off his back.
Walter smiled, took a deep breath, and began
to type.
“SCP - 059.
Keter Class.
This anomaly is a radioactive mineral that
emits a unique radiation known as Delta Radiation.
Exposure to this radiation has caused strange
fungal growths on the infected...”
Wait, what was this supposed to be about again?
Oh well, it couldn’t have been that important.
It was November 20th, 2019, and the helicopter
circled far above in the freezing wind of
the Antarctic.
SCP Foundation Site Director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated
above-ground facilities
of Provisional Site-344-1.
Something about this place made him nervous.
Edgy.
And for good reason: Between 2003 and 2019,
twenty-nine Mobile Task
Force units and seventy-three
members of D-Class personnel had gone missing
here and never been found.
Monroe thought he was here
for a routine investigation
into negligence and mismanagement, but little
did he know, he was in for so much more.
This is the story of SCP - 5545, and one man’s
journey into his own worst nightmare.
Literally.
But this nightmare began a long time ago - 300
years, to be exact.
And like most nightmares, it started as a
dream.
That dream was one of expansion - national
powers across Europe wanted to be the first
to conquer the globe and
expand into new territories,
and sent countless exploratory missions off
into the unknown to achieve this goal.
Any history book will tell you that the first
outsiders to lay eyes upon the continent of
Antarctica did so in 1820 - the reality is
that the first ones to get there actually
landed in the late 1700s.
The hapless explorers ventured into mainland
Antarctica and made base camps, before searching
and digging for any useful resources nearby.
They came upon a strange discovery: A hallway,
hidden beneath the ice.
Not a passage in the ice, but a true hallway
- complete with light fixtures.
The confused explorers ventured down into
these impossible hallways, and for many of
them, it would be the last thing they ever
did.
No matter how long they walked, it seemed
like the hallways just kept going.
As they continued to walk for hours, they
hoped they’d find something… anything.
And eventually, they did.
They passed from these hallways into somewhere
different altogether, and most of them were
never heard from again.
Those who did manage to escape often died
or took their own lives soon after.
Whatever it was they’d discovered down there,
they didn’t want to live with it on their
minds.
It’s believed that over seventy colonial
explorers disappeared or died this way and
that most who found these endless hallways
beneath the Antarctic ice never returned.
The multiple anomalous objects and phenomena
that make up SCP-5545 came into the Foundation’s
hands several centuries later on September
18th, 2003, when during an expedition into
the Antarctic, they too found the endless
hallways.
The Foundation built Provisional Site-344-1
around them, hoping to safely seal them off
from any other unwitting Antarctic explorers
or researchers.
But there was something else lurking beneath
the ice in Antarctica.
Something dangerous.
The hallways were designated as SCP - 5545
- 1 and were thought to be the extent of the
anomalous activity at the site, but soon SCP
- 5545 - 2 was discovered, which resulted
in the deaths of sixteen researchers.
So what exactly is 5545 - 2?
It’s an entity so volatile that even knowing
about it is considered to be a containment
breach, and - as a result - it’s kept in
Provisional Site-344-2.
Unlike Site - 344 - 1, 344 - 2 isn’t a physical
space.
It’s conceptual, accessible only through
the endless hallways, created with the express
purpose of keeping 5545 - 1 and 5545 - 2 separate.
Why?
Because whenever the two come into contact,
the result is 5545 - 3: The network of endless
hallways expanding.
If they remained in contact, the hallways
would continue to expand and the entire planet
could be filled with endless hallways in just
four to six hours.
While the two are apart though, 5545 - 3 reverses,
but it always would take just a few hours
to throw the whole world into a chaos of infinite
hallways.
SCP-5545 has been given the classification
“Safe”…
Wait, we’re dealing with a mysterious and
volatile anomaly that’s claimed a huge number
of lives and still somehow eludes true Foundation
understanding, yet the official SCP Foundation
classification is “Safe?”
How could this be?
Monroe was the Director of Site - 58, and
was the definition of no-nonsense.
Prior to taking the Site Director position,
he was a decorated member of Mobile Task Force
Eta-10 and helped contain numerous Keter-Class
anomalies.
He’d been around the proverbial block when
it came to anomalous activity, and something
about SCP - 5545, and the
management of Provisional
Site 344, seemed awfully suspicious to him.
And he had questions.
Like how such an unpredictable anomaly could
be declared “safe”?
And why had there been such
a lapse of communication
between the Foundation and Doctor Gabriel
Reed, who’d been running the facility for
the past two decades?
And most of all, just what exactly was the
mysterious SCP - 5545 - 2?
Monroe started to believe that something terrible
had happened at the site, and Reed was covering
it all up.
But to find out for sure, he’d need to go
to Antarctica and investigate it himself.
Information around this supposedly “Safe”
anomaly was highly classified - those without
O5 clearance could face termination for snooping.
But that didn’t scare Jason Monroe.
He’d dealt with Keters before, he could
deal with this.
Or so he thought.
Monroe submitted a request and was granted
unanimous approval by the O5 Council to travel
to Provisional Site 344 and get to the bottom
of this mystery.
He took a chopper to the base soon after,
armed with a concealed firearm and a Hostile
Meme Detector - or HMD - to test whether the
base and its staff had somehow fallen under
a hazardous memetic effect from SCP - 5545.
He’d find the answers, or die trying.
The moment Monroe arrived, he couldn’t help
but notice the strange way the staff behaved.
They seemed listless; almost depressive.
When he showed his credentials to a researcher,
they simply said “SCP-5545-2 is contained
in Site-344-2.”
His request to see Dr. Reed that night was
denied.
Dr. Reed was busy, he was told.
Wait until tomorrow.
The next day, Monroe met with Dr. Reed, but
the results of the meeting were underwhelming
to say the least.
Just like the rest of the staff on the site,
he seemed exhausted, as though he hadn’t
slept in days.
His responses were quiet and evasive, and
he refused to tell Monroe anything that wasn’t
in the official files already.
Monroe ran the conversation through the HMD
and found nothing out of the ordinary.
What was going on here?
Monroe was irritated, but not deterred.
Nothing would stop him from finding out the
truth.
The next day, he flexed his O5 credentials
and hacked into the base’s security system.
This gave him access to cameras around Site
- 344 -1, but more importantly, there was
a single camera inside the mysterious Site
- 344 - 2.
Jackpot.
But when he looked at it, the feed was an
entirely black screen with the words “SCP-5545-2
is contained in Site-344-2.”
The footage of the staff in 344 - 1 was equally
strange: The eighteen employees on site all
sat at computer banks, with nothing but static
playing on their screens.
Monroe kept digging though, and was able to
hack into the security footage of Dr. Reed’s
office.
As he watched, he discovered a fifteen minute
period where Reed left the office each day.
He could use this brief window to break in
and collect more intel on SCP - 5545 - 2.
Monroe was so wrapped up in the investigation
that he almost forgot the more immediate danger
around him, and nearly wandered into one of
the endless hallways of 5545 - 1 by mistake.
He made a note to be more careful in future...
His first attempt at breaking into Dr. Reed’s
office didn’t produce many answers - one
piece of evidence was a blurry picture of
what looked like a Mobile Task Force entering
a 5545 - 1 hallway in the dark.
Another was a spreadsheet featuring all the
personnel, living or dead, who’d worked
at the site - but one name, and the details
of whether this person was alive or dead,
was completely redacted.
Anything particularly juicy was hidden behind
O5 clearance.
If Monroe wanted the answers, he’d need
to break through.
That night, he had a horrific recurring nightmare,
one that had plagued him since he joined MTF
Eta-10.
He dreamed he was in a fancy dining room with
a grand fireplace.
The room was full of statues of men and women.
The men looked angry, and the women looked
afraid.
As he approached the fireplace, the ceiling
extended infinitely up into the darkness.
Suddenly, the zombie-like body of a teenage
girl appears in the fireplace, hanging from
a long thread.
Her eyes look furious and full of rage, and
Monroe somehow knows that he’s the reason
for her hate.
When he steps into the fireplace in this dream,
she attacks him, the two intertwine, and they
burn forever.
The one difference was that in this new iteration
of the dream, he blinked upon entering the
fireplace, and suddenly, he was in a hallway.
He awoke sure that something was terribly
wrong here, but he couldn’t give up now.
The next day, Monroe broke into Dr. Reed’s
office and made a horrifying discovery.
He found files indicating that Dr. Reed was
knowingly sending Mobile Task Forces and D-Class
personnel into the infinite hallways of 5545
- 1 to their doom.
He also found evidence that
Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him, somehow intercepting
copies of the notes he had been taking.
That’s when Dr. Reed entered the office
and interrupted him.
Monroe panicked and drew his weapon, holding
the doctor at gunpoint.
He was breaking so many Foundation rules,
but right now, he feared for his life.
The doctor seemed unbothered by Monroe’s
threats though.
He told Monroe that everything was going to
plan, and that he should go back to his room.
Monroe was becoming increasingly paranoid
- he felt that, at any moment, guards might
burst in and execute him.
Nothing about this place made sense.
He worried he was going insane.
Perhaps the only way to find answers was to
go even deeper: To risk it all, and venture
through the endless hallways to find SCP - 5545
- 2 himself, and finally discover what this
thing actually was.
Monroe left his room and stepped into one
of the endless hallways of 5545 - 1 that was
located just across from his dorm.
He found that it was a hallway like all the
others on site - Plain concrete, worn with
age, with simple light fixtures on the walls.
He walked for hours, recording with a concealed
device.
The lights suddenly went out, leaving him
in complete darkness.
When they flicked back on, he was in a very
different environment: A grand, old carpeted
hallway, the kind you’d see in an old mansion.
He broke into a cold sweat.
What was so familiar about this place?He kept
walking, wracked with terror, until this new
hallway finally led him to the place he’d
been seeking: Site 344 - 2, the domain of
5545 - 2.
It was a large, poorly-lit room, filled with
grimacing statues and a large fireplace at
the far end.
It was the exact same room from Monroe’s
dream - with one horrifying difference.
Monroe noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling, and when he
looked up to find its source, he screamed.
There were hundreds of bodies hanging and
swinging from the ceiling above him - everyone
who SCP - 5545 - 2 had ever killed, including
MTF members, D-Class Personnel, and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of years
before.
And all of them were him.
Every single one.
They had his face.
And there, hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level, was the body of a teenage
girl, the one from his dream.
In that moment, he finally recognized her:
She was the girl he killed.
The first him.
Hundreds of years ago.
Much like Monroe, you’re probably wondering:
What is going on here?
Thanks to declassified communications between
Dr. Reed and the O5 Council, we can tell you.
Jason Monroe is a man who’s been reincarnated
hundreds of times over the last three hundred
years, ever since he murdered a teenage girl…
A girl named Emily… his daughter.
This murder sparked the existence of SCP - 5545
as an eternally recurring punishment for his
crimes.
Since figuring this out, the Foundation has
kept tabs on Monroe’s reincarnations - whether
they’re MTF members, D-Class personnel,
or even Site Directors.
They see to it that these reincarnations always
find their way back to 5545 - 2 to take his
punishment, and prevent the infinite hallway
expansion that threatens to destroy the world.
It’s a plan everyone is in on - everyone
except him.
But every time he enters that nightmare-haunting
room, it all comes rushing back.
In that moment though, he knew his crime,
and he somehow knew how many times this punishment
had unfolded for him.
He now had two choices: Repent and accept
the punishment again, or leave and activate
5545 - 3, potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world.
Like his many predecessors, Monroe made the
decent choice.
He accepted his punishment and allowed his
own string to coil around him as the lights
in the room went off, one by one, leaving
only darkness.
Jason Monroe - that version of him, at least
- was never seen again.
But The SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation, and preparing to let
this twisted cycle play out all over again.
It skitters in the dark - its insect-like
legs tapping across the marble floors as terrified
Foundation researchers flee.
They hear its voice - the deep, silky tones
of an elderly British man, spouting nonsense
like “The nightmare is a dream to the nameless
slug that wanders across minefield and the
remains of deer and kings.”
While the scientists run, the creature gains
on them.
It’s fast.
Impossibly fast.
While they still try to escape down this darkened
hallway, earsplitting containment breach sirens
blast through the air.
They may try to escape, but it’s futile.
In a sense, they’re already dead.
All they are now… is prey for the Heart
of Darkness.
When someone says the word “heart,” there
are a lot of images that come to mind.
You might think of Valentine’s Day, heart-shaped
cards, and candies.
You might think of heartbreak, rejection,
loss.
You might simply think of
a heart in the anatomical
sense, the vital organ that pumps blood through
our bodies.
It’s unlikely though that you would associate
the word heart with terror, destruction, and
countless deaths.
However, employees of the SCP Foundation might
think differently, especially if they’ve
ever had a run-in with SCP-058.
Much of the information about SCP-058’s
discovery is highly classified, but the few
details that are known paint a chilling picture.
At an SCP Foundation test site, the day was
proceeding as usual with scientists and security
personnel going about their regular daily
tasks.
There was no hint of danger in the air - beyond
the base level that always comes with setting
foot in an SCP Foundation site, at least.
Several researchers were performing an experiment,
the specifics of which have been expunged
from all records, involving the carcass of
a cow.
When a researcher, Dr. C, placed his hands
on the specimen and prepared to dissect it,
he was shocked to feel a pulse coming from
the supposedly dead animal.
Dr. C shared his surprise with his colleagues,
but his concerns were dismissed immediately.
Clearly, this was a corpse.
He was imagining things, they said.
After all, he was relatively new to the job.
It was probably just nerves.
The head researcher, Dr. L, insisted that
he take over.
Pushing Dr. C to the side, Dr. L began to
make an incision into the animal’s chest.
As he did, he too felt something peculiar.
There was no doubt about it.
This dead cow had a beating heart.
He looked up from his work to tell the other
researchers, to explain what he felt, but
by then it was too late.
Something horrible was already happening.
With a stomach-churning sound of squishing
flesh, the cow’s heart burst from its chest
and flopped onto the floor.
It was terrifyingly large and all the doctors
jumped back from the sight of it.
Four spindly, spider-like legs poked through
the flesh of the heart, and it began to quickly
skitter about the room.
Researchers reviewing the security footage
would later note that it didn’t just move
randomly.
It seemed agitated, angry at being discovered,
and it displayed immediate hostility toward
the scientists in the room.
Four tentacles next unfurled from within the
heart and stretched out into full, writhing
appendages.
They moved frighteningly fast as the heart
whipped around the room, and were coated in
sharp spines.
Finally, a stinger poked out from the back
of the heart, where the hole of the superior
vena cava should be.
All of the scientists leapt into action, with
one reaching for a scalpel and another moving
towards the door.
But before the men could so much as call for
help, the tentacles wrapped around them and
ripped them to shreds.
Hearing screams coming from the laboratory,
security personnel arrived to contain the
threat.
However, they were no match for the strange
creature that would soon be known as SCP-058.
It tore through the security team in minutes,
leaving their tattered remains in its wake.
Much to the horror of the surviving personnel
at the site, SCP-058 was
able to escape containment
and make its way to a neighboring town.
Reports of the incident said that, when the
creature reached the town, you could hear
the screaming for miles.
SCP-058 carved a path of violence through
the town, attacking everything in sight with
its stinger and tentacles, and leaving a trail
of strange fluid from its stinger.
Dozens of citizens were killed, and seventy
percent of the buildings
were completely destroyed.
When agents were dispatched to the location
to retrieve the creature, they were shocked
to see the level of destruction caused by
something so small.
The scent of blood and smoke filled the air
and severed limbs littered the ground alongside
splintered wood and collapsed brick.
The survivors removed from the wreckage were
inconsolable, only calming down once they
were given an amnestic to erase their memory
of the encounter with SCP-058.
They had to be given new lives as well, as
there was nothing left of their old ones.
SCP Foundation Agents were only able to capture
and contain SCP-058 after it was crushed by
pieces of a building that collapsed on top
of it.
They found it, flattened under a slab of stone,
legs flailing uselessly, tentacles limp.
The agents were able to safely remove the
debris and bring in the heart without any
more casualties that day.
Once it was brought into captivity, the heart
was contained for three weeks, and remained
largely quiet during that time.
It was almost inconceivable that this small
creature hadn’t been killed in the incident
- but the Foundation would soon learn that
this creature was freakishly durable.
It escaped once more while being transferred
to an SCP Containment Site, again causing
injuries and death.
Having only experienced SCP-058 in its docile,
injured form, the team responsible for the
transfer was unprepared for the sheer power
and violence the creature was capable of.
It was able to escape an armored car and make
its way into a forest, where it eviscerated
several squirrels and rabbits.
Or rather, they were believed to be squirrels
and rabbits.
The remains were too mutilated to properly
identify.
It was only finally apprehended after being
crushed by an armored tank.
But even this didn’t kill the creature,
and it was transferred to Armed Bio-Containment
Area 14, where it remains to this day.
There is a great deal about SCP-058 that is
horrifying, but there is one attribute it
has shown in captivity that would make even
the most seasoned researcher’s skin crawl.
Though it has no anatomical capacity for speech,
no throat, vocal chords, or even a respiratory
system, SCP-058 speaks.
Not only does it speak, but it speaks constantly,
in the deep voice of an elderly British man.
No one knows who the voice might belong to,
or if it belongs to anyone at all.
Perhaps it belongs only to SCP-058, somehow.
As is often the case with SCP’s that are
capable of speech, there have been multiple
attempts to interview the creature and each
time it ended in complete disaster.
The only interview with an available transcript,
Interview 058-04, was conducted by Dr. Johnston
with several personnel in the room for additional
security.
Dr. Johnston attempted to get at the origins
of the creature, asking for its name and where
it was from.
The creature responded in cryptic, unsettling
poetry, giving answers to simple questions
with “I had dreams of the queen wonders
that lived inside the hearts of love and silent
treatments of all the elderly that I knew
were once whole.”
After the fourth recitation of a similar verse
from the heart, Personnel D-067 made a comment
on the creepy nature of its responses.
Almost as if it was offended by the remark,
SCP-058 immediately stretched a tentacle across
the room, wrapped it around D-067, and lifted
him into the air.
He began screaming and clawing at the tentacle
in an attempt to free himself as his fellow
personnel tried to help him.
They grabbed at the tentacle, but found their
hands pierced and bloodied by the spikes that
cover it.
Dr. Johnston commanded 058 to let him go,
but it did not oblige.
Instead, the man was crushed to death by the
tentacle, and his limp body left to drop to
the floor.
The interview concluded with a single statement
from the nightmarish heart: “The sensual
violence of lust is all the assurance you
will ever need to know the worth of life.”
SCP-058 never seems to say anything that has
to do with the people or events around it.
It speaks in the same haunting, poetic language,
even when it’s attacking or killing something.
No matter what happens to it, what is done
to it, or what anyone says, SCP-058 keeps
talking and its tone of voice with the pace
of speech never changing, and further attempts
to interview it have been abandoned due to
the safety risk involved.
So what happened to the creature often called
“the heart of darkness?”
Where is it now?
SCP-058 is kept in an isolated containment
chamber made of reinforced heat-resistant
steel with a backing of reinforced concrete.
In order to placate its bloodthirsty, carnivorous
tendencies, the creature is given a live cow
every three days.
It is uncertain how exactly SCP-058 eats,
given that it does not have a mouth or stomach,
but every time it is finished with a cow,
only bones remain.
Routine maintenance is conducted on a tight
schedule, and the heart is never allowed out
of its containment area under any circumstances.
After two previous escapes from containment,
the Foundation is not taking any chances.
Its constant speech is recorded via audio
devices that are running at all times.
Out of concern for their safety and mental
health, no personnel are permitted to listen
to recordings of SCP-058 speaking for more
than thirty minutes at a time.
It is unknown what will happen to someone
who listens for longer, but it has been suggested
that the consequences could be dire.
If the creature ever escapes
again, the containment
site is ordered to be destroyed via the detonation
of an on-site nuclear weapon.
Under no circumstances can it be allowed to
make its way out into the world again.
Even with all of these precautions in place,
SCP-058 has been responsible for over 150
deaths at its current containment site.
There are some at the Foundation who have
campaigned for SCP-058 to be terminated, believing
that there is more harm than good done by
keeping it alive.
However, all attempts to terminate it have
so far failed.
No matter how much physical trauma the heart
suffers, it does not seem to be able to be
killed.
It can only be incapacitated for a short time.
There is a classic horror story by Edgar Allen
Poe called The Tell-tale Heart.
In it, a man murders an old man and buries
his body beneath the floorboards of his home.
There, even though the old man is certainly
dead, the murderer swears he can hear the
beating of the heart coming up through the
floorboards.
No matter what he does to quiet the sound,
he cannot escape it, and is eventually driven
mad by the incessant beating of the dead man’s
heart.
SCP-058 may not be a man’s heart, a human
heart, or even a real heart at all.
However, just like the tell-tale heart, it
continues to impossibly beat no matter how
hard anyone tries to stop it.
The steady thump of its pulse haunts the SCP
Foundation, a grim reminder that there is
something within its walls that can, and will,
kill everyone it can if given the chance.
It couldn’t be destroyed by collapsed buildings,
an armored tank, or an army of experts, and
the contingency plan of a nuclear blast is
not even guaranteed to work.
It is entirely possible that, once the facility
has been laid to waste and all of the staff
have been incinerated, and the smoke has finally
cleared, the heart of darkness will still
be there… still beating, still talking,
and still killing.
It all started in 1983 with reports of human
trafficking in the heart of Sin City.
The FBI had gotten word of a potential trafficking
ring operating out of an abandoned department
store in Las Vegas, Nevada, and immediately
began organizing a secret raid on the building.
While they would indeed encounter something
horrifying within that abandoned department
store, it wasn’t criminals or human trafficking.
In fact, it wasn’t human at all.
This is the horrifying story of SCP - 847.
After weeks of planning,
the raid on the department
store was conducted in the dead of night.
Agents covered all the exits and entrances
and a helicopter was stationed nearby in case
anyone attempted to run.
It should have been a perfect trap.
But things never go as planned when you don’t
know what you’re dealing with.
The agents breached the door, and began searching
the darkened building.
It didn’t appear that there was any power,
so the traffickers must have had great night
vision and a high tolerance for creepy locales.
Agents soon heard a faint humming sound coming
from below - a generator.
It must be located in the basement and be
the hub of this criminal enterprise.
Readying themselves for whatever they were
about to find, the agents descended into the
basement.
As they moved deeper into the building, they
found that lighting rigs had been set up - they
must be getting closer to something, but that
“something” was still a mystery.
A senior FBI Special Agent was leading the
charge, his pistol drawn and ready.
It was quiet.
Too quiet.
Did the traffickers already realize they were
coming and clear out?
He was ready to consider this bust a bust
when he heard a quiet mewling in the distance.
A persistent, whining whimper that was undeniably
human.
He gave the signal to his fellow agents to
follow the noise.
They proceeded forward towards the pained
sounds and found themselves in a wide, well-lit
room filled with department store mannequins.
All were broken to some degree - some were
totally smashed to pieces, some were chained
to walls and locked in cages, others were
wrapped in plastic.
The agent wondered whether this was some kind
of twisted joke, or a messed up avant garde
art piece.
That’s when he noticed Her: A single, crouched
figure in the distance,
hunched over and whimpering
in a darkened corner of the room near a
full-length
mirror.
He couldn’t fully make her out, but he got
the sense that something was wrong - she was
injured, bent over.
Was she even missing an arm?
Just what had these monsters done to this
woman?
He whispered a request for back up into his
radio, and pushed on.
When they got within 50 meters of the strange
woman, her demeanor changed entirely.
She jerked around - her movements forced,
erratic, and painful-looking.
The woman stared directly into the agent’s
eyes and began hobbling towards him., occasionally
stopping to strike a pose as if modelling
during a photo shoot.
Just then the agent made a horrifying realization
- this thing moving towards them wasn’t
a woman at all, it was a living mannequin.
As she got closer though, he also realized
that the mannequin’s broken left forearm
had been carved into a large shiv.
A female junior FBI agent had been one of
the many to pour into the room when the raid
leader had radioed for backup.
The second she entered the fifty meter range
of this strange mannequin, everything changed.
In an instant, its eyes and mouth began dripping
with a thick, viscous resin.
Its whimpering gasps suddenly became vicious,
earsplitting screeches, and it turned its
gaze from the senior FBI agent.
It was now focused on the junior agent who
had just entered the room and broke into a
terrifying run straight towards her.
The mannequin moved with a violent, single-minded
purpose.
Other agents began firing but it was running
freakishly fast and easily dodged most of
the bullets.
The few that actually hit seemed to do nothing
to slow the creature down.
It shrugged off the damage and kept running.
With a great leap, it landed on the terrified
junior agent, and began jabbing at her with
its bladed arm.
The other agents stopped firing, fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague during
the panic.
The mannequin was ruthless, clawing and stabbing,
with the strange resin leaking out of its
every orifice.
Terrified and unable to reach her gun, the
agent remembered her training - she reached
into her belt and grabbed her stun gun, jamming
the two probes up against the creature’s
chest and giving it 30,000 volts.
The creature spasmed, fell backwards, and
collapsed in a heap on the ground - frozen.
This was the first recorded encounter with
SCP - 847 - a violent living mannequin with
a serious problem with women.
This terrifying report was passed up the chain
of command until it landed on the desk of
a Foundation Agent working in the FBI.
The Foundation quickly swooped in and claimed
the mannequin, delivered necessary amnestic
treatment to all who’d witnessed it, and
closely observed the female junior FBI agent’s
recovery in a private hospital with Foundation
ties.
As it turns out, they were right to do so,
as the junior agent was in for a gruesome
fate.
While the wounds she’d suffered at the hands
of SCP - 847 didn’t appear fatal, the fact
that the mannequin’s anomalous resin excretions
entered the open wound changed everything.
Several hours after being committed, the junior
agent began complaining of limb stiffness
and difficulty moving.
This quickly developed into full paralysis.
Over time, her skin and internal organs began
to harden, until the process - dubbed plastination
- came to a gruesome end.
The junior agent wasn’t just dead, she had
been transformed into a mannequin.
Foundation researchers were met with a truly
horrifying realization - This meant that all
the other broken mannequins found with SCP
- 847 were likely once living humans, attacked
and transformed by the anomaly, now a source
for new harvested body parts.
Now safely interred at a Foundation containment
facility though, the real tests on SCP - 847
to determine its behavior and physical attributes
could begin.
The most important detail about SCP - 847
is that its aggression is exclusively directed
towards women, as opposed to when it encounters
men and its instincts are more self-destructive.
Through a series of tests and observations,
researchers have been able to pin down three
different distinct patterns of behavior for
SCP - 847.
Pattern Z behaviors occur when there are no
humans standing within fifty meters of SCP
- 847.
The mannequin will seek out a full length
mirror, and pose in front of it, much like
a department store mannequin attempting to
show off its clothes.
It remains largely inanimate during these
periods, and will very occasionally use a
finger - or whatever appendage is available,
given its habit for self-mutilation - to scratch
messages on nearby surfaces.
Pattern Y behaviors occur when male humans
with XY chromosomes enter a fifty meter radius
around SCP - 847.
Just like its reaction to the male FBI agents
who found it, 847 will
initially emit vocalizations
that seem like whimpering gasps, before making
eye contact and striking provocative poses
while approaching the subject.
It will then remain static, and allow the
male subject to pose its body.
However, after the male subject leaves the
area, 847 will enter a state of considerable
distress, and begin removing or shattering
parts of its body.
The Foundation has found that the parts removed
or shattered are often consistent with parts
that the male subjects found displeasing during
interactions, showing a masochistic desire
to impress.
These parts are then harvested back from
plastinated
victims.
Which brings us to the most dangerous of its
behavior patterns.
Pattern X behaviors occur when female humans
enter a 50 meter radius around the creature.
847 will immediately become brutally aggressive,
switching its noises from whimpers to violent
screeches and growls.
847 also experiences enhanced
physical capabilities
during Pattern X states - its speed has been
measured at 45 kilometers per hour, making
it as fast as the legendary SCP - 096.
It’s also been shown to exhibit extreme
physical strength.
It’s during this pattern of behavior that
it begins excreting its deadly resin, which
has been proven to only be dangerous to women.
In these states, the only thing capable of
reliably pacifying the being is a powerful
electric shock.
The shock causes the creature’s resin to
harden, temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly five minutes.
Other conventional weapons and damage has
no meaningful effect on SCP - 847.
After a number of incidents that had sad and
violent endings, the Foundation Ethics Committee
forbade the use of female D-Class personnel
in SCP - 847 testing.
When it came to female subjects, 847 always
slipped into a state of extreme aggression,
so instead the Foundation began testing with
male subjects in hopes of better understanding
the dynamics between human males and SCP-847.
Various misogynistic D-Class males were introduced
into the containment chamber, which was modelled
to look like a bedroom for the purposes of
behavioral study.
Each one, either during or after their interaction
with SCP - 847, was told to comment on some
aspect they felt dissatisfied with.
The mannequin shattered its own chest after
hearing it described as being out of proportion.
After another D-Class called its nose ugly,
the mannequin broke it off.
After another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability to
drink, it tore out its hair and liver.
All parts were replaced after the experiments.
Things took their most violent and upsetting
turn yet with the introduction of D-7294.
A lot of the time, D-Class
personnel are considered
to be as anonymous as they are expendable.
But D-7294 is an exception.
Before becoming D-Class, he was a successful
cello teacher who brutally murdered one of
his teenage students and her mother.
He’s typically employed in tests when the
Foundation wishes to see interactions between
anomalies and humans with confirmed psychopathic
personalities.
During his interaction with SCP - 847, he
belittled and humiliated the mannequin.
He forced it into uncomfortable poses, and
even snapped off one of its fingers before
being dragged from the room by Foundation
guards.
In the following debrief, he further berated
the mannequin as “useless” and “lousy”
at its job of being controlled by him.
In response, 847 extracted its own brains,
eyes, and clavicle before shattering its own
hands in dismay.
So why does SCP - 847 behave this way?
While it may appear monstrous, it seems that
the reason SCP - 847 does what it does is
all too human: It hurts women because it itself
is hurting, and it’s willing to hurt itself
even more for the approval of the objects
of its desire.
As a result, it’s an anomaly trapped in
an endless cycle of pain and violence.
Perhaps one day it’ll be able to free itself
from the loop, but that day is unlikely to
come for this murderous mannequin anytime
soon.
London is the second largest city in Europe,
and underneath this bustling city is one of
the oldest and largest networks of train tunnels
in the world.
But that's not the only huge, old structure
located beneath the city of London.
Below even the deepest underground metro stations
of this historic city, there's a whole artificial
world of surveillance cyborgs, impossible
architecture, and stomach churning nutritional
supplements.
So be sure to mind the gap, because we're
about to take you on a tour of SCP-1678, also
known as UnLondon.
SCP-1678 is located one kilometer below the
city of London, England.
From all appearances, it seems to be an exact
copy of the city, though aesthetically, it's
more in line with how it was around the turn
of the 20th century.
Gas streetlights stand on every corner, and
the modern skyscrapers of the business district
are recreated in the style
of Victorian architecture.
The epicenter of construction appears to be
the houses of parliament, which is evidenced
by the more unfinished and flawed the city
becomes further out from the center one goes.
Some of the buildings are made of nonsensical
materials like copper pipes, and some of the
'gas lamps' are nothing more than a ball of
disembodied light floating atop a metal pole.
The first big question that the Foundation
had upon discovering this location was, of
course, why on earth was it created?
And they wouldn’t have to look far, as an
explanation of this bizarre mirror city plays
automatically upon entering -
“My fellow citizen.
If you are hearing this tape, then the world
as we knew it has finished.
The sky has broken, the ground heaves with
the tramp of terrible feet, and all the horror
and madness from the dark corners of the world
has broken free to exact its vengeance on
the world of Man.
Evil has raised its bloody flag upon all nations
of the world and crowed its unholy victory
to the broken sky.
Yes, this is the end.
But there is a new hope.
Welcome to UnLondon, a city of the survivors,
a city of the free.
Together, fellow citizen, we will wait and
prepare for the new beginning, the grand new
world that is soon to come.
Let the world above burn.
We will endure.
Let the monsters have their world.
We will prepare.
We will wait.
And I tell you, citizen, that there will be
a new morning.
And you will emerge from UnLondon, and stand
blinking in the sun.
And on that day, citizen, there shall be a
new order, as we raise the Union Flag over
the entire world.
I welcome you to UnLondon, the Last City.
And the first.”
From this message, it seems that this mirror
city was built to be a refuge for survivors
of an apocalyptic scenario, but the SCP Foundation
had no knowledge of such a plan.
In fact, it's still unknown who created this
place, or how they did it.
The one fact that was evident to the Foundation
was that even though this strange place was
intended to be a safe haven, it was far too
poorly constructed to actually act as one.
Illumination was unreliable, and most of the
buildings were damp and infested with mold.
It's also unclear to the Foundation where
the oxygen and gas supply of UnLondon was
coming from.
Throughout the day, the loudspeakers around
UnLondon play automated messages such as “No
one is safe from the influence of memetic
beings.”, “Bryson’s Home for the Poor
is here to help.” and “Crime will not
be tolerated in UnLondon...The tormentors
of society will become its defenders.”
At the end of every hour that passes, the
speakers announce the time, followed by “...and
all is well”.
When the SCP Foundation first entered UnLondon,
it was unknown whether or not any living things
inhabited the city.
On first investigation, it seemed from its
state of disrepair that the city had been
long abandoned.
But soon the foundation met their first inhabitant
of the underground city.
Mobile Task Force members were inspecting
the area around the houses of parliament when
they discovered what looked to be a bank.
As they approached the doors, they heard the
following announcement over
the nearby loudspeakers:
“Citizen, you are entering a restricted
area.
Have your authorization papers ready.
A Bobby will arrive to escort you shortly.”
This signaled the approach of SCP-1678-A,
also known as 'the bobbies'.
A single instance of SCP-1678-A appeared with
the unmistakable sound of a police whistle,
and as soon as it arrived it started attacking
the members of the task force.
Another announcement came over the speakers-
‘‘Police!
Halt, criminal!’’
The bobbies are the main threat to visitors
in UnLondon, and they will attack on sight
with any improvised weapon they can find.
True to their name, they are all dressed in
uniforms consistent with those of London city
police officers from the Victorian era.
What sets them apart from their historical
counterparts, is their construction.
These beings are made out of human corpses,
crudely dismembered at the joints and re-assembled
using metal hinges and bolts, with their heads
wrapped in bandages.
Bobbies are extremely hard to kill, with only
high-caliber rounds and explosive weapons
being effective at putting them down.
Autopsies of dead bobbies have shown that
underneath the police uniform, the bobbies
all wear prison inmate-style jumpsuits.
This adds a chilling context to the announcement
about 'the tormentors of society becoming
its defenders'- it appears that the bobbies
are the reanimated bodies of prisoners.
In addition to the bobbies, the Foundation
cataloged two additional forms of artificial
life present within UnLondon.
First are SCP-1678-B, or Eyes in the Sky,
hybrid bio-mechanical birds made of flesh
with an exoskeleton of copper wiring.
Some of these creatures are
covered in a deteriorating
outer layer of plastic and feathers, suggesting
that they were originally meant to resemble
pigeons.
As their name suggests, eyes in the sky serve
as a type of surveillance drone, and while
they have no offensive capabilities, they
still pose a significant threat to the Foundation.
It's still unclear whether they're able to
communicate with or summon the bobbies, but
the SCP takes no chances.
The last 'life form' present in SCP-1678 is
the strangest and the most
frightening - SCP-1678-C,
known as the wretch.
The wretch has only ever been encountered
outside the zone which is now under SCP Foundation
control, and it's uncertain how many instances
of this being exist.
The wretch resembles an old woman, or sometimes
old man, dressed in filthy rags.
The wretch sits at street corners holding
a begging tray, and will attempt to elicit
pity from anyone who happens to walk by.
The wretch will ask for food or money, but
if food is supplied, it will start weeping
before vanishing into a puff of black smoke.
On a few occasions, audio notices playing
on the city's loudspeakers have alluded to
this being, saying “Do not pity the Wretch.
Allow them to pay the price of their betrayal
for all eternity.”
The current Foundation protocol with regards
to the wretch… is to not engage with it
at all.
In addition to the bobbies, the eyes in the
sky, and the wretches, there's another strange
component to the world of UnLondon.
Throughout the city, in any area designed
for human habitation, the Foundation discovered
multiple machines that resembled modern gas
pumps.
These machines are fitted with coin slots
and rubber hoses that, when coins are inserted,
dispense a porridge-like substance advertised
as 'Dr. Goody's Wonderfood'.
According to posters around the city, Wonderfood
is a meal replacement supplement, supposedly
containing all of the required nutrients for
survival.
Wonderfood also appears to be the only food
source available in UnLondon.
Despite the claims by various posters around
the city that Wonderfood ‘Contains all the
nutrients you need!’ and ‘Completely restores
health and vitality!’examination of the
substance has revealed that it is, much like
the rest of UnLondon, unsuitable for sustaining
life.
Tests have confirmed that Wonderfood is a
synthetic starch gel heavily enriched with
various minerals, vitamins, fats and bulking
agents, and it contains artificially engineered
DNA helix structures.
While it does contain all the elements required
for short-term survival, consuming the product
for longer than 6 weeks will result in severe
malnutrition and eventually scurvy.
Further tests have shown that Wonderfood also
contains certain psychoactive properties.
The porridge contains a mixture of unknown
molecular compounds which, through regular
consumption, make subjects calmer, less anxious,
and less likely to resist authority.
It also seems to have been engineered to cause
withdrawal symptoms that set in if a person
stops eating it, symptoms which include headaches
and depression.
Foundation personnel are forbidden to consume
Wonderfood, but the substance is highly attractive
to instances of SCP-1678-B and 1678-C.
Like most things in UnLondon, the quality
of Wonderfood varies wildly, with some dispensers
putting out a product that is so degraded
that it can cause sickness, deformities, or
even death in the consumer.
But strangely, the Foundation has also recorded
a type of unknown colorful mollusk which feeds
on spillage from the Wonderfood dispensers.
At present, UnLondon is only partially contained.
Mobile Task Forces Tau-4 and Epsilon-6 have
succeeded in establishing a perimeter around
the Hyde Park district where they have managed
to stop any incursion from SCP-1678-A. Even
though this is the only area that is fully
under Foundation control, explorations have
been conducted of buildings
outside that perimeter.
The investigations are vital for the Foundation's
main purpose in UnLondon, which is figuring
out who built it, and exactly what kind of
event this underground mirror city was meant
to prepare for.
The interior of the Natural History Museum
yielded particularly strange insights into
the purpose of UnLondon.
For the most part, the museum is close to
how it appears in the above ground, but with
one key difference.
The task force investigating the museum discovered
an exhibit called 'The Fall of Man', exactly
where the Darwin Wing should have been.
The exhibit, as its name suggests, details
the apocalyptic scenario
that would've theoretically
driven people underground into UnLondon.
But, to everyone’s surprise, its dioramas
and displays didn't depict an asteroid impact,
plague, or nuclear armageddon.
To the Foundation task force members, the
scenes of destruction depicted in the exhibit
were far more familiar.
They recognized the reptilian form of SCP-682,
the ordinary-looking brownstone basement door
that serves as a gateway to SCP-2317, and,
most chillingly, the imposing many-eyed figure
of the Scarlet King.
These were only some of the known Keter class
SCPs depicted in the museum exhibit.
It was clear that even though the SCP Foundation
hadn't built this city, whoever did knew a
lot about the SCP Foundation's activities.
It's believed by the Foundation that whoever
or whatever created UnLondon still resides
in the houses of parliament, and the ultimate
goal of the task forces is to infiltrate the
building.
But in order to do that, they will first need
to find where the bobbies are made and halt
their production.
It's believed that Bryson's Home for the Poor
is where they originate from, but it's unclear
exactly where the materials to make them come
from, nor is it clear just how they're produced.
Ultimately, the Foundation's goal is to catalog
the entire city, and, once they have stopped
the production of more bobbies, MTF Tau-4
and Epsilon-6 will storm the houses of parliament
and contain whatever force has created UnLondon.
But, London is a very big city, and UnLondon
is just as big.
So, there's no telling what else they might
find exploring this bizarre location.
Have you ever had a nightmare that you’re
running down a long, dark hallway, getting
chased by something you can’t see?
The thing behind you isn’t fast, but that
doesn’t matter.
You can’t run forever, and the thing knows
it.
It is a patient predator.
It toys with its food.
At first, you move with speed and rhythm.
The metallic scraping noise behind you grows
quieter.
You run and stumble through the dark.
Your muscles start to ache and your lungs
burn.
Your pace slows.
It’s still coming.
You can hear the scraping getting louder.
You start to panic.
It’s completely dark.
You don’t know where you’re running or
even what you’re running from.
All you know - as you bump against the walls
and the sharp corners that rush towards you
- is that you can’t run forever.
You trip, fall, and pain explodes through
your leg as your knee shatters on the concrete
ground.
That scraping is getting louder.
You can barely breathe.
You can’t run anymore with your injury.
There’s no way to stop what’s coming.
There is no escape.
The scraping is right behind you.
You scream.
And then… you wake up.
Your heart is pounding like thunder in your
chest and your sheets are soaked with sweat,
but you’re safe.
You’re out of those awful, dark hallways.
But what if this wasn’t just a nightmare?
What if this scenario was real, and there
was no escape from the horror chasing you
in the darkness?
That’s what it’s like to have a close
encounter with SCP-1918, a sadistic, sentient
object that loves playing twisted games with
its prey.
But this monster never plays fair, and even
worse, it’s always just a simple door away.
It might even be hiding behind a door near
you, right now, waiting to start a game with
its new playmate.
But soon you’ll understand why some doors
should never, ever be opened, and why some
games are better left unplayed.
x
SCP - 1918 is an anomaly with two parts: SCP-1918
itself, and SCP-1918-2, the monster’s underground
lair.
The duo are a match made in hell, as the chambers
and hallways of 1918-2 are perfectly tailored
to 1918’s violent hobbies.
Nobody knows how long this anomaly has been
operating, but it’s probably behind countless
disappearances.
After all, 1918 has a habit of breaking its
toys...
The nightmare began in a small town in Maine,
with a population of only 226 people.
But that population was about to get lower.
People in the town began to report strange
noises at night, a droning, metal-on-concrete
scraping noise, like someone dragging a lead
pipe along the ground.
At first, people just ignored the sound.
It was all in their heads, or maybe just a
faulty oven or a washing machine on the fritz.
Anything that would allow them to forget about
the noise and get on with their daily lives.
But the noises were coming from below.
They could be heard out on the streets, most
audibly near manholes and sewer grates.
People started feeling unsafe in their homes.
The noises were spooking animals and children.
People were losing sleep.
That scraping they all tried to ignore was
beginning to get to them all.
Letters, emails, and angry phone calls to
the town council were piling up.
Something had to be done before the whole
town went crazy with fear.
The mayor authorized four utility workers
to investigate the source of the noise at
a local sewage treatment facility.
Considering the scraping was loudest near
the sewer grates, everyone just assumed that
whatever was causing all this must be connected
to the sewers.
Four utility workers were sent to investigate
the facility, only to find that the machinery
on site was working just fine.
The source of the problems must have been
coming directly from the underground sewer-lines
themselves.
The four workers, equipped with headlamps,
descended into a long service tunnel that
fed into the sewer system.
As they passed deeper into the tunnel, the
darkness around them became thicker.
It was a tangible presence that drowned out
the light of their headlamps, similar to the
anomalous phenomenon exhibited by SCP - 087.
When the utility workers tried to turn back,
they discovered another impossibility: It
seemed that the tunnel behind them had become
a solid concrete wall.
They were trapped, but where?
It was too dark to tell.
Confused and terrified, the four men stuck
together, attempting to find a way out.
It was too dark to see their hand in front
of their face, so all they could do was navigate
slowly by feeling the walls around them.
These walls felt oddly...crusty.
There was a kind of faint, metallic stench
hanging in the air, too, like old blood.
Something horrible had happened here, and
something horrible was about to happen again.
All they could do was keep moving and try
to stay calm.
Eventually, after hours of pawing at walls
in the dark, they found an open doorway.
One by one, they filed inside, only to feel
blinded when bright, white ceiling lights
suddenly switched on.
The room was all white, and filled with pipes,
large and small, running from wall to wall.
Just then one of the utility workers let out
an ear-splitting scream and pointed towards
the doorway.
His colleagues turned, and gasped in shock.
There was something outside the door, and
it was staring at them.
The object filled up almost the entire doorway.
It seemed like a demonic hobby horse, made
from a black-and-white, candy-striped metal
pole with a crude plastic head on top.
The head looked like a clown’s, with a wide,
toothy grin, but no visible eyes.
It was SCP-1918.
The utility workers were frozen as the object
leaned forward slightly, and slithered into
the room, the bottom of the metal pipe scraping
against the ground.
It was the exact same scraping noise that’d
been haunting the concerned townsfolk up above.
This was the thing behind it all.
And as the object moved, its metal pole started
to scrape words into the ground: Tik Tak Tow
None of the four utility workers were ever
seen again.
It didn’t take long for the SCP Foundation
to descend upon this quiet Maine town and
pick up the pieces.
All relevant officials were provided amnestics,
and cover stories were
created for the disappearances
of the four utility workers.
The Foundation also commandeered the sewage
treatment facility that held the entrance
to SCP-1918-2, replacing all key roles at
the facility with undercover Foundation personnel.
SCP-1918 was given a Euclid' classification
due to the fixed nature of its hunting grounds,
and then the real research began.
The Foundation soon made
some disturbing discoveries.
Entrances into the SCP-1918-2 area didn’t
follow any kind of logic.
The hunting ground of SCP-1918 can be entered
from almost any location, if you’re unlucky
enough.
There are currently 9 known entrances, including
5 sewage grates, 3 utility shafts located
in a sewage facility, and 1 toilet.
And these are just the ones the Foundation
knows about.
There are a huge number of
ways to enter SCP-1918-2,
but to this day, nothing has ever been able
to leave.
SCP-1918-2 is contained twenty meters below
the streets of this unassuming Maine town.
Personnel, aside from Foundation-approved
D-class guinea pigs. are refused entrance.
Researchers have mapped out the layout of
1918-2 through seismic imaging of SCP-1918’s
movements.
There are 18 identical room pairs in SCP-1918-2,
or 9 compound rooms.
Rooms are differentiated between a '1' room
and a '2' room by crude carvings on the floors
outside of the individual rooms.
SCP-1918-2 is symmetrical, with half a meter
wide paths circling each compound room.
The only deviations to this construction are
the location of entrances on the sides of
each individual room, which vary randomly
while the location is “active.”
What exactly does SCP-1918 do in this private
little maze?
It plays games, of course.
Its two favorites - as indicated by the words
it scrapes onto the ground - are “Tik Tak
Tow” and “Memoree”
In Tik Tak Tow, 1918 moves to each “1”
room, leaving behind "X" markings on the floors
if the room is not already marked with an
"O" in a manner similar to a game of "Tic
Tac Toe''.
How a victim is meant to accomplish making
a mark or understand this process is unknown,
as no aides are given.
Blood is commonly used by victims to make
their markings, hence the rusty smell in many
of the rooms.
In Memoree, the trapped victim is rendered
unconscious by blunt force, presumably from
SCP-1918.
The subject regains consciousness in a random
section of the facility.
Success is marked by finding a “1” room
identical to the central room.
This event seems to possess a time limit,
as the subject is pursued by SCP-1918 throughout
the halls of the facility.
The subject "wins'' by marking the correct
room with an "O".
What happens if you win or lose these games?
It’s important to note that SCP-1918 is
very competitive, and doesn’t play fair.
If you win, the object will merely accuse
you of cheating, and start a new game.
This will happen again and
again, until eventually…
you lose.
And when you do?
Well, take the horrifying encounter D-Class
personnel member D-2934 had with SCP-1918.
Wearing video and audio equipment, D-2934
was led into SCP-1918-2 by Foundation researchers.
When he eventually found his way to the central
room, 1918 challenged him to a game of Tik
Tak Tow.
And, against all odds, D-2934 won the game.
But 1918 didn’t take kindly to that.
It accused D-2934 of cheating, carving its
accusations into the ground before challenging
him to a deadly game of Memoree.
After hours of chasing, D-2934 eventually
lost his mind and was backed into a corner
by 1918.
As the object made its way towards him, he
panicked, ripped a pipe from the wall, and
began smashing 1918’s head.
As the plastic cracked under the force of
the blows, Foundation scientists could see
real brains inside.
D-2934 screamed, and the video feed cut off.
When the video turned back on some time later,
1918 stared into the camera with a different
head mounted atop its metal pole.
One that, just a few hours earlier, had belonged
to the unfortunate D-2934.
If there’s one lesson to be learned from
this terrifying anomaly, it’s that there
truly is no escape from SCP-1918.
You’re on a road trip - the kind that stretches
over days on end, and you need to make multiple
stops along the way to refuel the car and
yourself.
The last time you remember stopping to get
more gas and a bite to eat was back in Wyoming,
and now, you’re in the heart of Montana.
Thankfully, like an oasis in the desert, you
see the town of Clear Water off in the distance.
It’s a vibrant, welcoming little place,
a perfect slice of classic, small-town Americana.
You took a similar trip last year, and vaguely
remembered stopping at Clear Water that time
too and you’re glad to be back.
In particular, you remember the Old Prairie
Diner, a folksy little place with the most
delicious Huckleberry Pie you ever tasted.
Perhaps it’s about time for you to give
it another try.
You fill up your tank and stop at the diner.
The food tastes just as good as you remember,
but one thing is off: The entire staff seems
to have changed.
It’s the exact same diner you ate in a year
ago, no doubt about that, but it looks like
everyone from the wait staff to the cashier
to the cooks have all been replaced.
You try your best not to think about it, after
all, businesses are allowed to replace their
staff, but the longer you sit in the diner,
the more uncomfortable the feelings become.
You need to ask someone, just to push away
the fears that you’re going crazy.
When a waiter passes by, you compliment the
food, and mention that you ate here last year
too.
You ask the unfamiliar waiter if they had
worked here back then.
They confirm that, yes, they’ve always worked
here - and so has everybody else.
The diner is a family business.
You leave town not too long after that, feeling
vaguely unsettled, and as a voice on the radio
warns about the incoming rain, you tell yourself
that you never want to return to the town
of Clear Water, Montana.
As you leave, the memory of the town seems
to fade from your mind in real time, but little
do you know, the people of Clear Water will
never be able to leave.
Ever.
It’s because something horrifying will happen
in Clear Water every single year, and that
thing is known to the SCP Foundation as SCP-3300.
This annual anomalous event is Clear Water’s
own local curse, always occurring around mid-June.
While many of the mechanics of this event
still elude the Foundation’s understanding,
the outcome is well-documented: Every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a person
who didn’t previously exist.
While some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts, every person involved
will simply be a whole new person, with no
memories of the change or who they once were.
The process known as SCP-3300 lasts between
six and eighteen days, and once the process
has begun, it’s impossible for any outsiders
to intervene.
It begins with rain - a light, dreary drizzle
at first, but each day, the rain gets worse.
Soon, it’s a storm, and then, a maelstrom.
Flooding, hurricanes, tornadoes, all centered
around Clear Water, but cutting off neatly
just beyond it.
What happens in Clear Water remains in Clear
Water, and when the process has concluded
and the sun shines once more, everybody has
been changed .
Whenever the Foundation has tried to send
personnel or equipment into Clear Water during
SCP-3300, one of two things have happened:
In the more favorable scenarios, those attempting
to enter Clear Water have simply appeared
on the other side of the city limits.
In the less positive instances, personnel
and equipment have been lost forever within.
There is no stopping or even understanding
SCP-3300.
According to Foundation records, Clear Water
has been around at least as long as the Foundation
itself, perhaps even longer.
Clear Water has been able to undergo its yearly
nightmare without intrusion due to a unique
cognitohazardous effect, which creates a kind
of mental block around memories of the town
for outsiders.
You won’t forget Clear Water, per se, but
you will find it increasingly hard to focus
on.
Like something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye.
There is no saving the people of Clear Water.
The horror will play out again and again and
again…
The Foundation has no first-hand knowledge
of what happens in Clear Water during those
horrifying eighteen days.
But one account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility.
During an excursion into Clear Water, the
Foundation managed to collect a diary belonging
to a woman named Margaret Lane.
To the best of our knowledge, Margaret Lane
no longer exists, but if the contents of her
diary are to be believed, then what goes on
in Clear Water during SCP-3300 is far worse
than we’d ever imagined.
Margaret first started her diary not long
before SCP-3300’s 1995 iteration began.
She was in the middle of a tumultuous time
in her life - freshly clean from alcohol and
drug addiction, forced to
live with her antagonistic
mother, and having peculiar and distressing
dreams.
In the first dream Margaret recorded, she
was...someone else, a woman living in a small
hut perhaps a century ago or more.
It was plague time.
She was looking down upon her daughter, bedridden,
her skin covered in painful-looking red blotches.
Her husband was already dead.
That’s when another man enters, a healthy
man.
He tells her that he’s found their salvation.
And then the dream ended.
Margaret woke up to a gray, dreary day.
There were clouds on the horizon.
The rain was coming.
It drizzled for the next few days, before
getting more intense - as one would expect
from an SCP-3300 cycle.
Of course, nothing seemed out of place to
Margaret.
Life carried on - she continued to stay clean,
resisting the offers of her old dealer, though
her relationship with her mother remained
frosty.
The rain started to get worse as voices on
the radio insisted that conditions would continue
to become more severe over the next few days.
They tried their best to maintain normality;
Margaret invited some friends - Jared, Sam,
Mike, and Isabel - to come over and play D&D
at her place.
That was when all hell broke loose.
While the group roleplayed, there was a furious
banging at the door, like whoever was knocking
was trying to bash the door down.
When Margaret’s mom opened the door to investigate
the commotion, she saw that an entire family
was standing there - a father, a mother, and
two young children.
The father immediately began furiously asking
why all these strangers were in his house.
When Margaret’s mother tried to tell him
that this wasn’t his house, he became increasingly
agitated, and walked straight into the home.
Margaret’s friends attempted to subdue him,
but he threw them off, displaying a supernatural
strength.
Margaret’s mom ran in with a golf club and
struck the mysterious man in the chest.
There was a nasty splat, but he didn’t seem
to react.
The golf club was just embedded in his chest,
having broken the skin and sunken in.
But there was no blood.
Just dripping water.
The father then pulled the golf club out of
his chest, and began beating Margaret’s
mother to death with it, all the while repeating
“My house” again and again, while his
wife and children watched with broad, sunny
smiles in the rain.
Somehow, Margaret knew that her mother was
beyond saving, and that there was no way of
defeating these things in
a physical confrontation.
All they could do was run out to Jared’s
van with the rest of the group and high tail
it to the police station.
But when they arrived at the station, the
doors were barred and it appeared empty.
As the torrential rain hammered down from
above, there was nothing left to do but drive
out of town and try to escape whatever madness
was going on here.
But that was easier said than done.
They drove for what seemed like hours on end
as the rain and the howling wind persisted.
Jared had been injured during the fight with
the strange family and his health deteriorated
further as the drive stretched on.
They should have left the town of Clear Water
a long time ago, but it seemed like they were
nowhere.
It wasn’t long before Jared was lying dead
in the back of the van, and now, there were
only four of them left.
They kept driving - afraid, grieving, hungry,
and tired - and Margaret took the opportunity
to sleep.
It was no time to rest, but she was so exhausted
that she had no choice.
Margaret had a continuation of her earlier
dream.
The different her, the dream her, was laying
the plague-ridden body of her daughter in
the river.
But she wasn’t the only one.
All the villages of her settlement were placing
the bodies of their dead in the river, as
the water washed around them and through them.
The bodies became one with the water, and
then, they became the water.
The water was everything.
When Margaret awoke, it was to the horrible
sounds of bubbling and boiling.
That’s when she saw that Jared’s body
was...dissolving.
No, not dissolving, evaporating.
It was bubbling and convulsing, like it was
made of water, until the entire thing burst
into a cascade of hot steam.
After that, Margaret and the others left the
vehicle and refused to get back inside.
Nothing was making sense.
It was like something out of a nightmare.
As they walked, the rain hammered down upon
them.
They couldn’t have been walking for more
than a mile when they crashed into something.
It was a sign - “Welcome to Clear Water.”
It was like the town itself had drawn them
back.
Mike refused to return to the town of his
own free will, and began walking in the other
direction.
Moments later, he was walking back towards
them in silence, though he’d never intended
to.
SCP-3300 had distorted his path, and brought
him back.
It was clear that Mike was shaken to the core
by the experience, but they had to press on.
They would head to the grocery store for food
and then to a sporting goods store where they
could hopefully grab some guns to fight the
violent, altered people who’d somehow appeared
with the rain.
But things didn’t go to plan - or what little
plan there even was.
Mike shot himself on the first night at Dirk’s
Sporting Goods, leaving only Margaret, Sam,
and Isabel alive.
Perhaps one of the most terrifying details
of Mike’s death was the fact he didn’t
even bleed, instead, the gaping exit wound
in the back of his head was just full of water.
Water was all that seemed to be left of them.
Sam, seemingly driven to the edge by the sight
of Mike’s death, grabbed a hunting knife
to perform an experiment.
She cut into her own skin, and was horrified
to see only water dripping out.
They’d all been “changed”, and they
didn’t know why.
That’s when the survivors noticed something
else: There were people standing outside in
the rain, hundreds of them.
Not a single one they could recognize, all
new people.
Waiting.
Sam said only one word, “Outside”, before
walking out of the hunting goods store and
disappearing into the crowd and the rain,
never to be seen again.
Margaret mused that perhaps, in the end, she
had the right idea.
To be taken, killed, erased, or changed would
be inevitable.
In the final entry in Margaret’s diary,
dreams blend with reality as her mind finally
gives out from the terror.
She realizes, in her final moments, that there
is no way out.
There is no escape.
There is only water.
Water is eternal.
The rain is eternal.
All will be changed.
And given the fact that no trace of Margaret
was ever found, save for her diary, all her
fears turned out to be right.
She was taken and replaced by SCP-3300, just
as will inevitably happen to all the current
citizens of Clear Water the next time SCP-3300
rolls around.
It will be as inevitable and as indifferent
to those it affects as tomorrow’s sunrise.
You cannot change the rain, but believe us,
in Clear Water, Montana, the rain can change
you.
You’re driving down a long highway, lost
in an area you don’t know too well, trying
to find the right turn that’ll have you
heading back towards your home.
You keep driving, the night-time quiet all
around you.
Deciding to try and break that silence, you
reach for the radio, turning the dial to filter
through all the garbled, distorted voices
and songs from nearby local stations that
are too far out of range to come through clearly.
You try your best to listen to the music from
one radio station, but eventually the sound
of the static only makes you wish for the
silence you were trying to break.
Your fingers nudge the tuning dial on your
car radio once again, and finally, something
comes through.
It isn’t loud or clear, but under the distortion
you can make out the sound.
And it isn’t a song, or even a late news
broadcast.
The first thing you hear sounds like a short
musical tone, only for about ten seconds.
Next, a young girl’s voice, speaking in
a language you don’t understand, even through
the distorted audio.
From her accent, you assume it’s Russian,
but you still have no idea what the words
she’s saying mean.
With nothing else to listen to, you let the
broadcast play.
Still driving along in the dark, with nothing
but the strange, adolescent voice to accompany
you, your mind begins to wander.
She sounds like she’s listing something,
but the rhythm of the words is somehow familiar
to you, even though you don’t speak Russian.
Then it hits you: she’s counting.
But you don’t feel smart for having worked
that out.
Instead, something about knowing that makes
your blood run cold.
You carry on driving through the night.
After a few short minutes, the Russian girl
stops counting and the musical tone plays
again under the distortion, leaving you alone
in the car once again, with nothing but your
thoughts and questions of what exactly you
just heard.
Thankfully, we have the answer: What you heard
was SCP-3034.
Since 1964, this same broadcast has been made
a vast number of times - 627 times in fact.
You’d have to be within two kilometers of
the broadcast’s point of origin to hear
it, where Foundation personnel have tried
and failed numerous times to triangulate its
source.
The numbers heard recited in the SCP-3034
broadcast are actually a
countdown from two-hundred,
read aloud in Russian.
All Foundation staff are able to do while
stationed at the nearby Provisional Site-3034
is scour radio frequencies for occurrences
of SCP-3034, checking their equipment is properly
maintained and calibrated before they are
eventually rotated off-site and replaced with
a new group of staff.
There is only one rule that any Foundation
members working at Provisional Site-3034 must
follow.
They are only permitted to send one radio
transmission with their equipment, a single
phrase in reply to the SCP-3034 broadcast:
“Vse Khorosho”, meaning “All is well”.
Receiving this, the countdown stops and the
broadcast ends, but never permanently.
SCP-3034 has been known to repeatedly occur,
seemingly at random.
The shortest recorded gap between broadcasts
was two weeks, while the longest so far lasted
six whole months.
You may have heard the term “numbers station”
mentioned before, but these are far from just
random numerical sequences, sent out over
the airwaves without purpose.
General speculation surrounding numbers stations
points to them being the tools of espionage
agents, a way of sending coded, highly-sensitive
messages or information without the risk of
compromising their cover.
The use of numbers station transmissions is
often attributed to spies working on foreign
soil, who utilize short-wave radio frequencies,
speech synthesis, Morse code and either regular
or sporadic timing schedules.
While it’s true that times have changed,
and technology has progressed considerably,
there appears to be evidence that numbers
stations are still used among various intelligence
and espionage agencies today.
Despite being considered an old-fashioned
method of communication,
these low-tech, short-wave
stations remain a viable, reliable option
for the transmission and reception of intelligence
to field agents.
The Conet Project is a comprehensive archive
of this phenomenon, and its founder, Akin
Fernandez, has long been fascinated by numbers
stations.
According to him, “This system is completely
secure because the messages can't be tracked,
the recipient could be anywhere.
You just send the spies to a country and get
them to buy a radio.
They know where to tune and when.”
So, what does the distorted broadcast of numbers
from SCP-3034 mean?
Is it the work of covert agents, and if so,
whose side are they on?
Most importantly, why does the SCP Foundation
make certain there are always three of its
personnel on-site, ready to send the “All
is well” message whenever SCP-3034 begins
broadcasting?
SCP-3034 was first discovered by the Foundation
in 1964, after a defector from the Soviet
GRU-P, a division tasked with acquiring and
studying anomalies on behalf of the USSR,
gave them a tip.
Commander Robert Malthus, along with a team
of six, including a man named Agent Browning
- selected for his knowledge of Russian dialects
- were sent to investigate at Provisional
Site-3034.
Here, the team uncovered partially-burned
records and logbooks all kept in Russian,
along with evidence that the site had been
evacuated shortly before their arrival.
Carved into a desk, also in Russian, were
two phrases: “Don’t let her finish”
and “Tell her all is well”.
On the team’s second day at the site, an
automated alarm sounded at 7:30am, alerting
them to the incoming SCP-3034 broadcast.
Following the instructions on the desk, Agent
Browning was able to stop the broadcast, telling
the young Russian girl that all was well.
A tape was partially recovered by the team
from the site, and translated from Russian.
The GRU-P members that had previously inhabited
the station had interrogated one of their
own, a man named Sergei, whom they accused
of stealing state property.
“She’s not state property,” he replied.
“She has a name.”
While his GRU-P superior accused Sergei of
planning to defect to the United States, allegedly
in exchange for money and asylum, Sergei denied
any collusion with America.
He claimed that the GRU-P at Provisional Site-3034
were meddling with powers they could not possibly
hope to understand.
His superior, a man named Vaslov, dismissed
this, claiming their work to be no different
to the United States’ experimentation with
atomic weapons at the time.
“One does not make deals with atom-bombs,”
Sergei argued.
“One certainly does not sacrifice little
girls to them.”
Shortly after this, a struggle broke out,
with Sergei having to be restrained, while
urging Vaslov to cease any and all interference
with “it”.
The man spoke of terrible nightmares that
he’d had, voices screaming in the darkness.
“That's what it wants, Vaslov.
That's what it is.
You cannot make a deal with this thing — we
have finally contained it, and now you want
to offer it —”
The tape’s audio ends shortly after this
point, with no clear answer as to what Sergei
was referring to, or what offer these Russian
operatives had made to “it’“.
Ever since the discovery of SCP-3034, members
of the SCP Foundation have worked tirelessly
to understand the purpose of these countdowns,
as well as determine their origin.
By September 2012, Doctor Schulkill was reaching
the end of his tether with the investigation
into the SCP-3034 broadcast.
Over almost half a century, the Foundation
had made well over 600 recordings of the Russian
girl’s countdowns, but still hadn’t determined
any noteworthy information.
They were prohibited from contacting the girl
via the same radio frequency, only permitted
to use the phrase that stopped her countdowns.
Running out of options, Schulkill contacted
his colleague, Doctor Emerson, asking for
an in-depth vocal analysis of the various
recordings of SCP-3034.
Even if they could narrow down where the broadcast
was coming from, maybe by determining the
girl’s geographical location from her dialect,
then that would be at least some slight progress
into understanding SCP-3034.
While unable to discover the girl’s location,
Doctor Emerson’s analysis did yield some
interesting findings.
Emerson learned that these countdowns were
not pre-recorded, the variations in the Russian
girl’s voice, her tone, her pitch, all seemed
to indicate that every instance of the broadcast
was unique.
Rather than using the same recording, this
girl had been counting down over and over,
hundreds of times for almost fifty years.
But there was more.
Schulkill and Emerson then
examined the distortion,
the sounds interfering with the audio of the
Russian girl’s countdowns.
What had initially seemed like garbled static,
seemed to actually be additional voices.
And much like the girl’s voice, these distorted
voices were unique, different in every broadcast.
However, Schulkill and Emerson were unable
to accurately determine what these voices
were saying.
Given that the girl’s countdowns were always
cut short by the use of the phrase “All
is well”, the doctors did not have long-enough
samples of the audio to analyze the other
distorted voices.
With permission from the Foundation, the next
five occurrences of the SCP-3034 broadcast
were allowed to carry on for longer, giving
the two doctors enough audio to determine
exactly what the distorted voices were.
And the results were extremely troubling.
They were screams.
Thousands upon thousands of children’s voices,
endlessly screaming.
Both Doctor Emerson and Doctor Schulkill agreed
that it would be best to continue responding
to SCP-3034 with the correct phrase, and refused
to analyze the distorted screaming audio any
further.
Three years later, while stationed at Provisional
Site-3034, a Foundation researcher named Doctor
Uriel Willis decided to take matters into
her own hands.
She conducted an experiment that had not been
sanctioned by the Foundation and attempted
to make contact with the Russian girl giving
the countdowns.
Hearing Doctor Willis’ voice, the girl stopped
her countdown.
After five long, painfully-silent seconds,
a new broadcast was heard:
A piercing, high-pitched
screech that caused extreme pain and dizziness
to all of the staff working on-site.
Unable to bear the disorienting sound, Dr
Willis told the girl “All is well”, and
caused the noise to stop.
The following day, SCP researchers noted there
had been a significant increase in cases of
missing children all around the world.
A majority of these disappearances happened
at the same time the screech had been broadcast,
and remain unsolved to this day.
Dr. Willis faced disciplinary action from
the SCP Foundation, and any further testing
of SCP-3034, and attempts to communicate with
the Russian girl, were prohibited.
Only one distinct change has been noted in
the SCP-3034 broadcast since this incident.
Almost a month later, the countdown was detected
and the correct phrase given.
But researchers noted that, instead of starting
her countdown from two-hundred, this time
the Russian girl began counting down from
199.
Nobody knows what will happen if the Russian
girl’s countdown is allowed to reach zero.
Personnel working at Provisional Site-3034
are told to always offer her the necessary
phrase before this point in the countdown.
Attempting to interfere with the broadcast
by contacting this girl directly not only
resulted in intense pain for SCP staff, but
also seems to have caused an unconfirmed number
of child disappearances around the globe,
as well as reducing the countdown starting
number from 200 to 199.
After a long night on the road, you finally
find the right turn, sending you in the right
direction.
As you drive through the night, you keep telling
yourself one thing, one small phrase over
and over again.
You hope the words will eventually give you
comfort, but deep down you start to realize
just how hollow they are, that it’s just
a lie we tell ourselves so we don’t have
to face the inevitable.
But still, what choice do you have but to
keep telling yourself that “All is well.”
The year was 1857, and the Second Opium War
was raging between China and the combined
forces of the English and French. It was one
of the many bloody colonial wars fought over
resources like tea, sugar, and the intoxicating
opium poppy. It was a war fought by peasants
and noblemen alike. One of these aristocratic
soldiers was the noble Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood, the quintessential English gentleman
and explorer. While his fellow soldiers cowered
behind cover, Lord Blackwood charged into
the fray, shouldering his rifle and firing
his pistol into the crowd of opposing soldiers.
It was the Battle of Canton, one of the most
crucial battles of the entire conflict. The
French and English were laying siege to the
city of Canton, also known as Guangzhou, to
prove their military dominance and capture
an important Chinese government official.
Lord Blackwood led the charge on horseback.
Every bullet seemed to find the heart of a
foe. He was a true hero among men; a gentleman
warrior with class, refinement, and style.
And it would be thanks to his expert leadership
and marksmanship on the field that the allied
European forces won the battle decisively.
Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood is a name that
deserves to be counted among Lord
Horatio Nelson, Sir Francis Bacon, and Sir
Walter Raleigh. In addition to being a skilled
and honorable fighter, Lord Blackwood is an
consummate explorer, naturalist, and frontiersman.
During his heyday, he traveled perhaps further
than any man across the known and unknown
corners of the globe. He made scientific,
biological, and anthropological discoveries
that should have reset the course of society
forever. And yet, you won’t find any records
in the history books of Lord Theodore Thomas
Blackwood. Nor will you find any grand oil
paintings, or dedicated wings in British museums.
This is because Lord Theodore Thomas Blackwood…
is a four and a half inch, telepathic neon
sea slug. And he’s known to the SCP Foundation,
as SCP-1867.
While he would never admit to it, Lord Blackwood
belongs to the species Nembrotha kubaryana,
also known as the variable neon slug. He’s
kept in a standard aquarium in a Foundation
containment site, and is physically no different
to any other member of his species. What makes
Lord Blackwood unique is his powerful telepathic
abilities - specifically, the power to communicate
by speaking directly into people’s minds.
And what’s more, he’s extremely talkative.
But to what extent is anything that this anomalous
sea slug says true? Or is he just like SCP-082,
Fernand the Cannibal - a creative and pathological
liar.
It isn’t committed to record how exactly
the Foundation discovered Lord Blackwood.
Perhaps a local aquarium worker worried they
were going insane when they heard the voice
of a nineteenth century English nobleman ringing
in their ears whenever they were cleaning
algae out of the tank. Maybe Lord Blackwood
was found by SCP Foundation divers, who are
constantly combing the ocean for anomalous
creatures and activity. What we do know is
that Lord Blackwood is an incredibly strange
and mysterious individual. He claims to have
visited locations all around the world, and
encountered rare societies and creatures.
The Foundation was skeptical about a number
of Lord Blackwood’s more outlandish claims,
on account of him being a sea slug, but he
does appear to have the knowledge to back
up his supposed experience. Interviews with
Lord Blackwood have shown that he’s extremely
knowledgeable in the areas of geography, zoology,
botany, archaeology, anthropology and linguistics
relating to his claimed regions of exploration,
as well as more esoteric fields such as obscure
mythology, mysticism, and cryptozoology. In
other words, if Lord Blackwood hadn’t gone
on his escapades around the globe throughout
history, how would he come to possess this
wide variety of information?
The Foundation was getting frustrated, and
began to probe further into the personal life
of the most interesting gastropod in containment.
Lord Blackwood, under questioning, was always
polite and amicable with Foundation staff.
He seemed to display no real knowledge of
the fact that he himself was a sea slug - going
as far to accuse other people of being crazy
or drunk when they brought the fact up to
him. While none of Lord Blackwood’s tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910, he told
fanciful stories of exploring the Americas,
and of his involvement in the Second Opium
War on the side of the English.
Naturally, the Foundation wanted proof. When
they pressured Lord Blackwood on this, something
even stranger happened: He gave it. The Lord
told his interviewers that he would happily
donate his collection to them, if it gave
them cause to believe what he was saying.
He gave the baffled Foundation researchers
the address of a cottage in England where
they could find the secrets to his bizarre
and mysterious past, and local agents in the
area followed up on the information.
Upon investigation, Foundation Field Agents
did indeed find the cottage that Lord Blackwood
had specified. It was being maintained by
an extremely old woman. When questioned about
her presence there, she said that she was
“keeping the house for Lord Blackwood”,
and gave no more useful information. Incidentally,
it appeared that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for. She
abruptly passed away from heart failure five
days after the Foundation commandeered the
cottage. Whether anything truly anomalous
caused this, we still don’t know.
At first, the cottage seemed normal, until
the Field Agents discovered a secret basement
housing Lord Blackwood’s “collection.”
They were amazed at what they saw: The basement
consisted of zoological and botanical specimens,
over three thousand artifacts,
a library containing
over five thousand items, and a functioning
1800s scientific laboratory. It took around
three weeks for Foundation agents working
round the clock in shifts to remove all the
items from Lord Blackwood’s mysterious collection,
and what they found raised even more questions.
The collection included, but was by no means
limited to: 116 unknown species of plants,
107 unknown species of insects, 28 unknown
species of lizards, 23 unknown species of
fish, 14 unknown species of amphibians, 12
unknown species of mammals, Fossils pertaining
to 8 unknown species of dinosaur, Fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of prehistoric
mammal, and Artifacts belonging to 29 unknown
indigenous societies. That’s a lot of unknowns!
But wait, there’s more! His collection also
contained a collection of seemingly unknown
firearms, including three wide-bore muskets
marked as “Dr. B. T. Moth’s Effective
Particle Destabilizers.” Detailed globes
of Mercury, Venus, Mars, and the Galilean
moons, accompanied by notes detailing possible
paths of surface exploration. A heavily modified
carriage, containing instruments of unknown
purpose. A note attached to the door reads
“On the fritz. Speak with Henry.” And
a highly dangerous and seemingly anomalous
machine that killed four Foundation Field
Agents before it was destroyed on site. And
when questioned about this little fiasco,
Lord Blackwood responded:
“I did warn you to be careful around my
collection. That bloody thing nearly took
my head off back in ninety-seven when I found
it.”
However, there was one thing recovered from
Lord Blackwood’s collection that was perhaps
more interesting than all
the others: 35 hand-written
journals containing recordings of events described
by Lord Blackwood in his grandiose tall tales
to the Foundation researchers. The accounts
are generally identical to the stories he
had told, save for some slight variations
and exaggerations on the part of Blackwood
in the re-telling. Most interestingly of all,
all of these journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events described
by Foundation scientists.
While his stories are too numerous to all
be shared here, there’s one that perfectly
sums them all up: Lord Blackwood’s account
of a possible encounter with SCP - 1000, also
known as Bigfoot, in Seattle during the mid-1800s.
Lord Blackwood, seeking to explore the so-called
“new world” of North America, embarked
with an assistant and an indigenous American
guide to the Pacific Northwest, in search
of the legendary Sasquatch. The trio was headed
for Mount Rainier, then known as Tahoma. During
the journey, Lord Blackwood found a young
fox caught in a trap that had been set by
a local tribe. He took sympathy on the animal
and freed it, allowing it to run away to safety.
That night, he and his assistant met up with
the rest of his guide’s tribe, and they
settled down for the evening. However, things
took a disastrous turn when the camp was raided
by a rival tribe. Almost everyone was slaughtered
in the process, and Lord Blackwood and his
two companions were hauled away by the enemy
tribe for a sinister purpose: Sacrifice to
a violent local deity.
As it turns out, the creature that this tribe
worshipped was the very same one Lord Blackwood
and the others were trying to find: A particularly
large and aggressive Sasquatch. Each night,
a different sacrifice was made to the Sasquatch.
The victim would be placed near a forest clearing
while the tribe played a primal song, and
the Sasquatch would emerge from the trees
to devour its prey. The first night it ate
the assistant, the next night it ate the guide.
And then, it became time for the sacrifice
of Lord Blackwood himself.
As Blackwood was presented for sacrifice,
he accepted his fate. But
instead of the Sasquatch,
a legion of woodland animals emerged from
the trees - foxes, elks, raccoons, and more
- themselves painted with tribal symbols.
The animals seemed to be on Lord Blackwood’s
side, and attacked the tribespeople who had
been holding him captive giving Blackwood
the chance to flee into the forest during
the chaos. Later, these same animals would
find Blackwood again, and present him with
the things his captors had stolen from him.
An elder fox also gave him a letter, proclaiming
him a knight of their people now. He was allowed
safe passage back to a nearby settlement,
at which point he wrote to his financiers
back in England, explaining the situation
and asking for more money to perform further
expeditions into the Tahoma region. The whole
incident had only increased his thirst for
adventure and exploration.
Whether this tale is actually true, or just
a bizarre, colonial fantasy from the pathological
mind of a telepathic sea slug, we may never
know - but it doesn’t make
it any less interesting.
To this day, Lord Blackwood continues to be
a perplexing but fascinating anomaly. He may
not be the most dangerous, and he may not
be the most useful, either, but there’s
no denying that perhaps we’d all like to
sit next to his tank for a couple hours one
day, and hear him spin a good yarn over a
warm cup of tea.
There’s a quote that says “the beautiful
thing about learning is nobody can take it
away from you.”
But what good is learning if the knowledge
might hurt you, drive you mad, or even kill
you?
It just sits there in your mind, like a stick
of dynamite with an invisible fuse.
It could blow at any moment.
All it’d take is a careless slip of the
tongue, and you might turn into a talking
home appliance.
This is a conundrum faced by anyone dealing
with an Infohazard - a certain kind of anomaly
often dealt with by the SCP Foundation.
Before we get into some of the craziest examples
of infohazards and what they’ve done to
people, because let’s face it, that’s
what you’re really here for, first we have
to answer that big question everyone’s a
little afraid to ask: Just what is an Infohazard?
And how does it differ from a far more common
type of SCP, the dreaded Cognitohazard?
Well we’re glad you were finally brave enough
to ask.
First, cognitohazards are anomalies that are
dangerous to perceive through one of the senses.
A well known example is SCP-096, which is
actually a visual cognitohazard.
You see its face, and you’re toast.
It’s as simple as that.
And cognitohazards exist for all of the other
senses too: hearing, taste, touch, even smell.
Infohazards, on the other hand, are different.
These anomalous effects are triggered when
you start trying to express or describe something
about what you’ve perceived, and when you
do, things start to get real weird real fast.
Maybe you’re trying to explain what you
just saw to family members, friends, or the
police.
Maybe you’re a member of SCP Foundation
staff, trying to write up a report, or a new
experiment log.
Or maybe you’re a YouTube channel, trying
to create entertaining yet informative breakdowns
and explanations of anomalies from the SCP
Foundation.
If any or all of these apply to you, then
Infohazards are going to be your worst enemy.
But as we look at some of the strangest examples,
we’ll try our best to resist their effects.
First, seeing as it’s so hot out, how about
we take a relaxing dip in the pool while we
tell you all about SCP-1128.
What is SCP-1128?
Well, that’s a loaded question.
Technically speaking, it’s a massive, predatory,
aquatic creature, but despite its huge size,
the creature can hunt its prey in any body
of water.
Whether you’re stepping in a puddle, relaxing
in the bath, or say, chilling out in the pool,
SCP-1128 can track you down and potentially
eat you alive.
In one particularly horrifying test, a D-Class
was drinking from a simple glass of water,
when the aquatic predator emerged, yanked
them inside, and ate them.
Okay, so maybe you’re feeling a little nervous
now, but don’t worry, you’re still safe.
Some people have even survived their attacks
from SCP-1128.
Well, their initial attacks anyway.
The creature has a tendency to come back,
again and again, relentless in its ravenous
hunger for human flesh.
Whenever it attacks successfully, all that’s
left is some blood floating on the water.
But again, please don’t worry too much about
this creature, we don’t have another 682
on our hands.
After all, it’s an infohazard, it can only
start hunting you if you receive a written
or verbal description of the creature.
Oh, or some kind of visual representation
of the creature, too.
Actually, on second thought, you may want
to get out of the pool.
Now.
And put down that drink too.
Instead, let us tell you a nice little story.
You step into a bar, smelling of fine liquor
and rich mahogany.
You even get a whiff of some fine, leather
bound book.
You see us sitting at the bar, motiong for
you to come over, and you decide to approach.
You’re intrigued by our winning smile, and
our vast knowledge of anomalies and SCP Foundation
lore.
You take a seat next to us and order a drink.
Get something fancy, it’s on our tab after
all.
Our treat.
“What does this have to do with Infohazards?”
you ask.
“That’s the thing about SCP-1893, kid,”
we say, our dulcet tones smoother than scotch.
“You can never just talk about it.
It’s an Infohazard that forces information
about it to be delivered like a story.
That’s why we’re in this bar right now,
that’s the set up.
It expresses actual information about itself
through the dialogue, see?”
You nod, beginning to grasp the concept, as
the bartender serves you your drink.
It’s been forever since you’ve been to
a bar.
Feels good to be out again, honestly.
You drink deeply, savoring the flavor, but
you almost choke when you see the man standing
in the corner.
He’s so large and so distinctive, it surprises
you that you hadn’t noticed him before now.
He stands in the corner, a freakishly tall
and muscular guy - like a basketball player
who decided to become a pro bodybuilder.
His muscular arms are bulging out of his white
vest, and a pair of bull’s horns are tattooed
across the top of his bald head, making him
look like the devil made flesh.
He stares at you with a subdued kind of annoyance,
as if to say that you’re not in real danger
quite yet, but if he wanted, he could grab
you and twist your head off like a bottlecap.
“What’s with the huge guy?” you ask
us, more than a little concern in your voice.
“Oh, him?” we reply with a smirk.
“He comes with the anomaly.
He appears in every SCP-1893 experience to
an extent, though his level of involvement
varies.
If SCP-1893 doesn’t perceive you as an annoyance
or a threat, then you’re good to go.
But if 1893 starts to feel like you’re gonna
cause it some problems, then the guy with
the horn tattoos is gonna intervene.
Speaking of which…”
You look up, and see that the giant man is
now standing next to you, brow furrowed in
visible rage.
He picks up your drink, and crushes the glass
in his hand without flinching, dripping booze
and blood onto the counter.
He snarls, “I think you’ve had enough,
buddy.
Now it’s time for you to leave, or we’re
gonna have to get physical.
Understand?”
You don’t need to be told twice.
You grab your hat, get up, and leave the bar,
abandoning us on our lonely stool.
But our next Infohazard still awaits…
You like poetry?
Japanese poetry, yes?
The humble haiku
It’s dear Nine Three One
A unique infohazard
It’s so poetic
Though specifically
It takes the form of haiku
So, what does that mean?
A rigid structure
The first line, five syllables
Then seven, then five
We can’t talk about this
In ways other than haiku
It is challenging
Object class is safe
It is kept at Site-19
Need third tier clearance
So, what is this thing?
SCP Nine Thirty-One
It is a rice bowl
White, with a blue band,
And a crackled blue pattern
All inside the bowl
And we must confess
We took that one from the file
Man, haikus are hard
Three inches in height,
Four point five inches across.
(Metric doesn’t fit)
No makers’ marks found;
Suspected to have been made
Late Nineteen Hundreds.
Really makes you think
On the skill of these poets
Sans anomalies
Sure, it can’t kill you
But writing these drives you mad
Curse Nine-Three-One
Trapped in this rhyme scheme
Makes the Old Man’s Torture World
Look like a resort
Okay let’s move on
Other SCPs to see
We’re sick of Haiku
Okay, back to normal.
Time to shake off the structure of SCP-931,
and talk about another iconic infohazard:
SCP-3007.
This incurable infohazard is a lot less whimsical
than a rice bowl that forces you to write
and speak in haiku, in fact, it’s literally
killed several people, and some in surprisingly
gruesome ways.
The main component of the Infohazard is known
as SCP-3007-1, this is an extremely vivid
anomalous hallucination that affects those
under the 3007 umbrella, known as SCP-3007-2.
To be afflicted with SCP-3007
is a truly horrifying
and debilitating condition.
The hallucinations occur an average of four
times a day, with each episode lasting for
as long as an hour - and during these episodes,
the victims are at risk of grievous bodily
harm, or even death.
So the question now is: What exactly is the
SCP-3007-1 hallucination?
To the people experiencing it, they appear
to be transported to a strange, alien world
consisting of a huge number of white towers
or pillars, stretching into the sky.
SCP-3007-2 specimens are trapped on a series
of bridges, incredibly far off the ground,
that connect these various structures.
This anomalous area is known as SCP-3007-3.
It’s important to remember that people transported
to this world still remain, physically, in
our own.
However, any damage sustained with SCP-3007-3
will carry over into our own reality.
To give one particularly gruesome example,
some people fall from the precarious bridges
and tumble to their deaths in SCP-3007-3.
Back in our reality, they suddenly explode
from the damage of an invisible high-speed
impact, killing them instantly.
There’s much more to SCP-3007, enough that
it probably warrants its own explanation,
and the SCP Foundation takes it extremely
seriously, believing that, if the infohazard
is allowed to breach containment and become
contagious, it could result in an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario.
As a result, anyone found to be infected by
SCP-3007 is contained and summarily terminated
to reduce the risk of it spreading.
To make things even worse, there are also
concerns about SCP-3007-3 seeping into our
reality, as those standing within a two-meter
range of SCP-3007-2 during a 3007-1 episode
can actually hear the sounds from the terrifying
hallucinatory reality.
Okay, that was a little scary.
How about instead of talking about falling
to your death without falling at all, we talk
about a nice movie.
Goncharov, by Martin Scorsese, one of the
best gangster movies of all time.
What, you’ve never heard of Goncharov?
It’s got everything - action, suspense,
romance, a mountain of black thorns, on which
lives a dark tyrant of terrible and unknowable
power.
You’re sure you haven’t seen Goncharov?
Well, here’s the thing, all signs point
to movies like Goncharov and many others simply
not existing.
This comes as a result of
SCP-2747, an infohazardous
phenomenon that causes people to talk about
works of fiction that don’t exist.
These works often feature commonalities, like
an ethereal or disturbing tone, ambiguity,
black thorns, and a sinister,
mysterious antagonist.
The Foundation is doing all they can to hunt
down and suppress SCP-2747, but it’s proving
more difficult than they’d imagined.
Currently, the leading hypothesis is that
these tales may have actually existed once,
but were erased from reality, leaving only
the residue of memory and the odd scrap of
evidence around.
Many researchers speculate that the various
pieces that form SCP-2747 are anafabula, pieces
of fiction accidentally composed with the
perfect elements to cause them to quite literally
erase themselves over time.
Now the greatest concern that the Foundation
has about these anafabulas is that they might
actually be one, and their reality is on the
precipice of collapse.
But we really don’t have time to unpack
that right now, and like SCP-3007, a full
explanation of this anomaly would take some
time and is probably best tackled on its own.
But there you have it, folks: Infohazards.
They say that knowing is half the battle,
but in this case, it’s the whole battle,
and if you know, you lose!
Not really a battle at all come to think of
it… more of a trap.
But whether it’s a vicious mega-fish, a
strangely buff man with bull tattoos, a poetic
rice bowl, or a nightmarish ordeal of daily
hallucinations, there’s no doubt that Infohazards
are some of the most strange and fascinating
anomalies that the Foundation has to offer.
Oh, and of course, how could we forget the
most well-known Infohazard of all: SCP-2521.
This entity is so infohazardous
that its Foundation
file entry is written in pictograms.
This is because, whenever information is recorded
about this entity, it manifests and steals
it.
If you write it down, it’ll take the paper.
If you make a note of it on a computer, it’ll
take the computer.
And of course, if you talk about it, it’ll-
Oh no, not again!
Ahhhh!
Phew, that was a close one, but I’m ok,
for now at least.
Agent Carla Mendoza was one of the best field
agents that Site 41 had ever seen.
She was professional, cool under pressure,
and when the situation demanded it, she could
be a straight-up badass.
During a Chaos Insurgency raid on the Site,
she’d single handedly killed four different
insurgents - the last one with her bare hands.
During containment breaches, she’d always
be the first one charging into the fray, her
Foundation standard-issue Beretta drawn and
ready to fire.
Agent Mendoza was so devoted to the job that
she took up the Site Director’s offer to
start living onsite, so she could always be
there to help if an emergency situation unfolded.
After all, when it all hits the fan, you want
someone as utterly unshakeable as Agent Mendoza
on your side.
The job had thrown the worst of the worst
at her, and she’d never even flinched.
So surely, nothing could scare Agent Mendoza,
right?
Right?
After a long day of kicking ass, taking names,
and filling in the properly mandated amount
of SCP Foundation debriefing paperwork, Agent
Mendoza retired to her Site 41 quarters.
She felt exhausted and sweaty, so before heading
to bed to watch some wonderful SCP Explained
videos on her phone, she decided to take a
quick shower.
The last thing she expected
was for this particular
shower to become...well, let’s say “Hitchcockian.”
The water was running, hot and clean, filling
the air with steam.
Agent Mendoza was lathering up her hair when
she first heard the noise: Heavy, wheezing
breaths coming from just behind the shower
curtain.
The second she heard it, Agent Mendoza felt
a kind of brutal, crushing anxiety that she’d
never experienced before.
Like a hand was reaching into her chest, and
squeezing her heart.
The self-defense training that’d been encoded
into her muscle memory over years of working
at the Foundation kicked into effect.
In a blind panic, she struck out at the shower
curtain, causing it to sway outwards - and
land directly on the face of Mendoza’s wheezing
voyeur.
Who or whatever it was, it was standing right
there, less than a meter away from the shower.
That wheezing carved into Mendoza’s ears
like a butcher’s knife.
What an awful, monstrous sound.
And despite the fact that the shower curtain
obscured its face, she could still somehow
see it, the way a defenseless animal can sense
an approaching predator without ever locking
eyes on it - and just somehow know that it’s
too late for them to escape now.
Every training session, every achievement,
every piece of battle-hardening experience
- it all evaporated in the presence of that
thing.
Mendoza was so terrified, she might as well
have been a child.
The monster just stood there beyond the curtain,
its raw, fleshy face parted into a freakishly
wide, yellow-toothed grin.
She didn’t know how, but on some deep, primal
level, she was aware that if this thing got
its hands on her, something horrific beyond
description would happen to her.
She was too terrified to even move a muscle
in its presence.
She remained like that, standing in the shower
and sobbing quietly, for the next three solid
hours until the creature finally disappeared.
When her colleagues found her, she’d experienced
moderate scalding wounds from the hot water
of the shower.
It took another several hours for Agent Mendoza
to compose herself enough to share her story.
A couple of days later, Tim Ellis, a junior-level
filing clerk, was found trapped in a Site
41 supply closet.
He’d urinated in his Foundation-issue slacks,
and was in a state of borderline catatonia.
When his superiors asked him why he’d been
spending two hours in a supply closet on company
time, he reported that it was because a monster
had appeared outside the door when he was
searching for a replacement stapler.
Despite never actually opening the door to
see what was outside or call for help - Mr.
Ellis said that he felt as though he would
have had a heart attack if he actually opened
that accursed door - he was able to provide
a clear description of the monster.
He said it was tall and
emaciated, with reddish-brown
skin that made it seem almost burnt or rotten.
While it stood there and waited beyond the
supply closet door, it let out the most awful
wheezing noise, like an old, rusty Iron Lung.
But the image that Ellis seemed most fixated
on was the monster’s face, or lack thereof:
Just a huge, grinning mouth that covered up
its entire head, stocked with an arsenal of
massive, yellow teeth.
Ellis was visibly shivering as he talked about
it.
Two incidents are an unpleasant coincidence,
but three are a bonafide pattern, and it didn’t
take long for more sightings of this strange
new anomaly - dubbed SCP-303, or The Doorman
- to pop up across the site.
It earned that name by always appearing behind
some kind of doorway, or at least a movable
divider, in the case of Agent Mendoza’s
shower curtain.
Whenever it appeared outside a doorway, nearby
Foundation personnel would report being struck
with a sudden paralyzing terror that made
engaging with the creature impossible.
Attempts to call for help were also often
stifled, as the very presence of the Doorman
causes disruptions to electrical equipment.
Whenever The Doorman manifests in your proximity,
it’s safe to say that it’ll be commanding
your absolute, undivided attention.
This was a particularly frightening case for
the SCP Foundation because it was one of the
few anomalies bringing the fight directly
to them.
Most sentient anomalous beings would do anything
to avoid getting captured by the SCP Foundation
and contained in one of their high-security
sites, full of experienced researchers and
state-of-the-art equipment designed specifically
to neutralize their effects.
The Doorman, however, just seemed to take
this as a challenge, turning even the most
hardcore personnel on the site into gibbering
wrecks with its mere presence.
But The Doorman was just getting started.
Agent Henderson had a frightening encounter
in the break room.
He was pulling a long shift, and just wanted
to grab some coffee creamer from the cabinet.
However, as he approached the cabinet, he
heard the telltale wheezing, and that terrible,
overwhelming terror set in once more.
The Doorman was sitting inside the cabinet
in the fetal position, he just knew it.
Could this thing really just appear anywhere
it pleased, and keep people in or out until
it decided to dematerialize and torment somebody
else?
When the creature finally dematerialized and
the cabinet was examined, the coffee creamer
was found to be missing, leaving Agent Henderson
distraught.
This was the first recorded instance of The
Doorman stealing a physical item, but it would
be far from the last.
Henderson wondered whether the creature that’d
just humiliated him was sitting somewhere
else now, sipping from a warm cup of joe with
its big, freakish mouth and laughing at him.
But a few incidents after this, things would
become considerably more serious: The Doorman
was about to take its first life.
Well, it isn’t really that simple, if you
want to get into the semantics of the thing.
When the body of Dr. Barker was found inside
the 2nd-floor storage room after a spree of
SCP-303 incidents, the question was naturally
posed as to whether The Doorman had gotten
more dangerous and finally directly attacked
one of its victims.
Not quite.
There had only been one way in and out of
the storage room: A secured decompression
chamber, and the Doorman had appeared inside
this chamber while Dr. Barker was in the storage
room, effectively trapping him inside with
the sheer terror it causes in its victims.
He was trapped in the room for a grand total
of five days, at which point he finally died
of dehydration, and the Doorman demanifested
shortly afterward.
The staff of Site 41 scaled
up their countermeasure
efforts, hoping to discover more about and
perhaps even trap and contain the infamous
Doorman.
Dr. Burroughs, Researcher Matthews, four members
of security personnel, and four D-Class operatives
formed a kind of strike team, ready for quick
dispatches whenever The Doorman happened to
manifest.
It wasn’t long before the creature appeared
in a room on the first floor, but the team
quickly intercepted its location, ready and
eager to gather more data on the mysterious
being that’d been terrorizing all of them
for weeks.
Dr. Burroughs ordered one of the D-Classes
to open the door and look inside, but the
D-Class refused out of fear.
The doctor told him that if he didn’t open
the door, he’d be transferred to SCP-682
duty.
The D-Class frantically shook his head and
said, “I’d rather take my chances with
the reptile than go in there.”
The doctor was getting frustrated.
He told the D-Class that if he didn’t open
the door immediately, he’d be terminated
right there on the spot.
The D-Class still refused, saying that he’d
take death over what the Doorman would do
to him if he stepped inside.
Without hesitation, Dr. Burroughs ordered
one of the security officers to shoot the
D-Class then and there.
The shot was fired.
The D-Class was terminated.
Dr. Burroughs then ordered a female D-Class
who’d just witnessed this callous execution
to open the door, or the same abrupt death
would befall her.
She still refused, then began to describe
the awful things she believed The Doorman
would do to her if she went inside.
Researcher Matthews was visibly shaken by
the descriptions.
Dr. Burroughs decided not to terminate this
D-Class immediately.
He instead wanted to see just how much pressure
the Doorman’s anomalous fear-based resistance
mechanisms could take.
Another D-Class was given a combat knife and
also given the order to cut the female D-Class
with it every time she refused an order to
go inside.
After two hours of repeated asking from Dr.
Burroughs, the female D-Class dropped dead
from blood loss.
At no point did she ever attempt to open the
door.
It seemed that, in all cases for those in
the thrall of the Doorman’s anomalous effects,
death is a truly preferable alternative to
ever facing it head-on.
It’s worth mentioning that these tests were
conducted back in the 1970s, before the formation
of the Foundation’s Ethics Committee, which
explains why their methods
feel a little needlessly
cruel.
Since then, The Doorman has fully commandeered
the second-floor storage room, the same one
where it caused Dr. Barker’s death.
It only ever leaves the room to steal more
items from around the site.
These items have included a cryotube, three
sets of standard Foundation surgical equipment,
two D-Class research
cadavers, one gasoline-powered
generator, a variety of chemicals from the
chemical storage areas, and of course, poor
Agent Henderson’s can of powdered coffee
creamer.
The reason for the Doorman taking an interest
in these particular items remains unknown,
but we can only assume that nothing good can
come of it.
And there you have it, folks, the strange,
frightening, and eerily inconclusive tale
of The Doorman.
All we can really say is that we’re awfully
glad he’s fixated on bothering Site 41,
because who knows what would happen if he
widened his net to the rest of us?
Thankfully, we won’t need to think about
that.
Oh, that’s odd.
Can you hear that?
I thought I was imagining it.
Though come to think of it, I can’t help
but feel a little uneasy right now.
Do you ever get that feeling you’re being
watched?
Wait...The door, there’s something behind
the door.
Can you feel it?
Can you feel its red flesh and rotten teeth
pressing up against it, breathing, waiting?
Can you feel it staring at you without eyes?
Looking deep into your very soul?
No?
Well, that’s good.
But just stay cautious, okay?
After all, life has many doors, and you never
know who or what will be waiting for you behind
the next one...
Growing up in a small Virginia town near the
mountains, right on the border of West Virginia,
Zane heard all kinds of
stories from his grandmother.
Tales of mountain lions who could transform
into ghostly women.
The tailypo, a fluffy rodent-like creature
on an endless quest to get its tail back from
the hunter who took it.
The Mothman that appeared with glowing red
eyes to warn of impending tragedy.
Most of all, she warned him about the deer.
"Sometimes," she used to say, "when you're
out in the woods late at night, you'll see
a deer acting a little bit funny.
Maybe it's making strange sounds.
Maybe it's standing up like a man.
Maybe it's staring at you from the shadows
and won't look away.
If you ever see one of these deer, promise
me you'll get away from it as fast as possible.
Don't look at it, don't talk to it, just get
far, far away."
He promised her every time.
But, as he got older, he started to forget
his grandma's stories, letting them fade away
with memories of the Easter Bunny and Santa
Claus.
He didn't think about the stories again until
he was older, a junior in college, and embarking
on a camping trip with his roommate, Josh.
They were both staying with Zane's family
for the summer, and had been enjoying the
sunshine and fresh air.
They'd gone hiking, picked blackberries, and
gone fishing to their hearts' content.
After a while, they got sick of sleeping in
the cramped house and decided to have a proper
camping trip out in the mountains.
Campsites were crowded this time of year,
but Zane knew a spot just isolated enough
that they could kick back, enjoy nature, and
relax in peace.
They packed their supplies and headed out
into the forest for a weekend they would never
forget.
By nightfall, Zane and Josh had pitched their
tents, built a fire, and were starting to
make some dinner.
They roasted hot dogs and heated cans of beans
over the fire, and decided to start telling
some classic scary stories.
Sitting by the crackling fire, listening to
the rustling leaves, snapping twigs, and the
chittering of animals all around, Zane couldn't
help but remember the stories he had almost
forgotten.
All of the strange, inexplicable things that
came out after the sun went down and the forest
went quiet.
He thought he could hear the footsteps of
something walking by their campsite, circling
them.
But it was probably just his imagination.
As Josh told stories about babysitters stalked
by killers and drivers picking up ghostly
hitchhikers, Zane was thinking about the deer.
He shuddered but shook it off, and after some
more stories and a few too many s'mores, the
two friends decided to get some sleep.
After several hours, Zane woke to the sound
of Josh unzipping his tent.
He sat up, ready to yell at his friend for
waking him up, but the sight of Josh's pale,
frightened face stopped him.
"There's something here..." was all Josh could
say.
His hands, Zane noticed, were shaking.
"Hey man, it's okay.
Let's check it out," Zane patted Josh on the
shoulder.
He was pretty sure his friend just wasn't
used to camping in actual nature, but reached
for his hunting knife just in case.
He grabbed a flashlight, and switched it on,
following Josh out into the darkness.
He swept the beam across the clearing, and
it illuminated a pair of orange eyes staring
directly at him from behind a nearby tree.
"What the..." he approached the shape, trying
to get a clear look at it.
As it became more illuminated, his stomach
dropped.
It was a deer, but something was...wrong with
it.
Its mouth was wide open, its jaw working up
and down like it was trying to make a sound,
but nothing came out.
But that wasn't the worst part.
As the flashlight beam illuminated the animal's
body, Zane realized that, somehow, its head
was on backwards.
"What the-" Josh appeared behind him, gasping.
"Shh!"
Zane shushed him intensely.
He suddenly remembered his grandmother's warnings.
"You know what?
I don't feel so great.
I think we should go back to the car and head
to my place."
He gave Josh a look, shaking his head as if
to say "don't say another word."
By the glow of their flashlights, the two
packed up their campsite, all under the gaze
of the misshapen deer.
They drove home in silence, Josh only speaking
once to ask: "What was that thing?"
Zane shook his head.
"I don't know.
But it wasn't a deer."
They crept back into the house, and went to
bed.
They knew they would never speak of tonight
ever again.
As Zane began to drift off to sleep, his last
conscious thought was to glance out the window.
There, in the yard not five feet away, was
a deer.
Watching.
He didn't know it, but that night Zane encountered
an instance of SCP-6448.
SCP-6448 is an anomalous species of creatures
that appear to belong to the Cervidae family,
nicknamed the "Not Deer."
They are highly intelligent
and can be distinguished
from ordinary deer by unusual behavior and
physical deformities.
Some of these have included: legs that bend
backwards, the eyes of animals other than
deer, forward-facing eyes, jerky movements,
lack of fear toward humans, and walking on
two hind legs.
Most notably, and most frightening, SCP-6448
instances will watch and stalk humans, for
a duration of hours or even days.
They will follow humans home, and steal items
from their domains including weapons, food,
and other personal items.
They are most frequently found in the deep
woods at night, when a person is completely
alone.
If someone encounters an instance of SCP-6448,
if they acknowledge any of the creature's
anomalous traits, it will attack.
In order to limit the loss of life and ensure
that SCP Foundation employees exercise the
utmost caution when dealing with SCP-6448,
the Cryptozoology Division issued the following
guidelines:
"If you notice a deer that seems “off”,
look away and ignore it.
If it knows that you’ve noticed it, it’s
too late.
If you hear your name, whistling, or something
else in the woods calling for you, don’t
acknowledge it.
Never acknowledge it exists, don’t respond,
don’t go looking for it, don’t call back
to it.
If you’re walking at night and you feel
something breathing on your neck or whispering
behind you, the key to your safety is pretending
that everything is normal.
Your survival is dependant on your ignorance."
Whatever SCP-6448 is, they
appear to be intelligent
enough to understand when they are being studied,
and they don't seem to like it very much.
On January 11, 1994, a group of three SCP-6448
instances broke into Site-41 in North Carolina,
using a tunnel they had carved over a long
period of time.
At that time, there was an
instance in containment,
but in all of the chaos of the breach, the
specimen was lost.
Every time an instance was captured and contained
near SCP-6448's habitat, it would later escape
via similar tunnels.
SCP-6448 was officially classified by the
SCP Foundation in 1980, but those from the
Appalachian region have known about these
strange creatures since at least 1947.
From folktales and campfire stories to secondhand
and even firsthand encounters, the locals
are well aware of the Not Deer's existence,
and are largely familiar with the precautions
necessary to avoid them.
Though many of the civilians that encounter
SCP-6448 avoid notifying the authorities,
there have been several recorded 911 calls
involving the Not Deer since 2000.
The following is a log of those calls:
February 1, 2000:
"Victim (aged 41, female) dialed emergency
services after hearing their name being called
from the woods near their home.
The victim recounts the vocalization being
likened to a scream in a voice that they do
not recognize and requested assistance in
locating the source.
Emergency personnel requested the subject
place their phone on the floor outside the
home to listen for the alleged sounds.
After 2 minutes, a vocalization was heard
that was calling to the subject by name, emanating
from the nearby forest.
The subject was instructed to investigate
the disturbance themselves and keep services
updated on the situation.
The victim then begins to walk into the woodland,
getting about 50 meters into the underbrush
before inexplicably stopping.
They claim there to be a noticeably large
deer standing in the way of the path.
She begins to walk closer, though states it
does not move.
Subject diverts from the path and begins walking
in a different direction.
After 30 minutes, no source of the voice is
determined.
The caller returns to their residence."
June 13, 2002:
"Victim (aged 28, male) calls 911 regarding
a home break-in.
The caller notes numerous items to be missing
from their residence and
requests an investigation.
Operators dispatch two investigators to visit
the home and pertain a potential perpetrator.
The pair note that, based on earlier CCTV
images, all cutlery, sharp objects, firearms,
lightbulbs, and a single copy of the novel
‘The Day After Roswell’ are missing.
Also noted is that there is a complete lack
of any fingerprints at the scene, with no
doors or windows having been broken into.
Analysis of the home’s CCTV footage revealed
there to be a two hour period of missing film,
with the exception of a single frame containing
a Cervus nippon on its hind legs, reaching
towards the camera.
Its frontal hooves have been warped to resemble
fingers.
No footage of the entity exiting the home
was discovered."
November 19, 2005:
"A cattle farmer (aged 54, male) reported
to local authorities the sudden disappearance
of over 30% of his largest herd.
Response teams searched the nearby area for
4 hours though found no trace of the cattle.
The victim was recommended to set up trail
cameras and note any unusual activity overnight.
At 01:11 AM, two SCP-6448 are seen walking
through the field before fleeing.
One places an object into the ground, later
discovered to be a single fork.
A week after this discovery, 200 discarded
bovine hooves appear at the location."
March 4, 2009:
"Victim (age unknown, gender unknown) dials
911 to request assistance from animal services.
The victim is standing within a forest in
front of a Cervus elaphus, which is violently
contorting.
The victim attempts to state "You better get
a vet or something, I don't think it's well"
before a piercing screech is heard and the
line falls silent.
Recovered footage depicts the aforementioned
animal squirming, seemingly in pain.
A viscous churning is audible as a black mass
erupts out of the instance, and the video
turns to static."
October 11, 2012:
"Victim (aged 23, male) is a junior wildlife
officer at Cherokee National Forest, Tennessee.
They radio their supervisor in the early evening
regarding a herd of Odocoileus virginianus
within the reserve.
Supposedly, there is a single animal that,
upon first glance, appears average, though
possesses divergent attributes, including
backwards joints, enlarged
abdomen, and forward-facing
eyes.
Upon stating this, a distant whistle is audible,
and the victim stumbles slightly.
They begin to say “What the he- did it just
whistle at me?”
before the sound of hooves rapidly getting
closer is heard.
Notably, the hoof steps did not sound to be
in the traditional gallop of a cervid."
October 12, 2012:
"The former victim’s supervisor calls authorities
following the victim’s absence from the
reserve night shift.
Following this, their radio begins to crackle.
The victim’s voice can be heard on the other
end, and he requests the supervisor’s attention.
He calls regarding a herd of Odocoileus
virginianus within the reserve.
They claim there is a single animal that upon
first glance appears average, though possesses
divergent attributes including backwards joints,
enlarged abdomen and forward facing eyes.
Suspecting the creature to be a rare genetic
malformation, the victim requests their supervisor
to come to the location.
The supervisor questions the victim about
what happened the night previous.
There is no reply.
Upon the supervisor’s and law enforcement’s
arrival at the site, a herd of approximately
80 Odocoileus virginianus was present.
A single entity is in the field’s center
and appears to be standing separate from the
rest of the group.
It flees the scene upon realizing the law
enforcement’s presence.
Where it formerly stood laid a standard two-way
radio."
April 8, 2016:
“Victim (aged 35, female) dials 911 using
a satellite phone, distressed.
They state that they are in [REDACTED] County
Woods and are being followed.
She claims that, despite seeing no one for
the duration of her hike, she “feels as
if she’s being watched” and has heard
someone walking behind her at various points
in the trip.
The victim is unable to
give an adequate description
of their location, but knows the route to
return to her residence.
Operators request the victim to return to
a point wherein she can provide a sufficient
geographic description of her position.
The victim remains on the line for the
duration of the hike back to a readily used
portion of the wilderness trail.
Along the journey, various unnatural sounds
can be heard.
These include footsteps, rockslides, coughing,
whispering, and whistling.
Nearing the main trail, all woodland noises,
such as birds and wind, cease suddenly, and
the victim states she can see a malformed
deer carcass coated in a thick layer of black
slime.
At this time, human screams can be heard in
the distance.
Operators request the victim continue and
ignore other stimuli.
Agents embedded in local law enforcement,
suspecting SCP-6448 involvement, notify Gamma-4
to the situation.
20 minutes later, the victim returns to the
main trail.
Gamma-4, now operating the 911 call, informs
the victim not to respond to any further unusual
activity and briefly outlines Cervus Protocol.
For the duration of the victim’s journey
to her home, two sets of breathing are audible.
The victim successfully returns to her residence
and shuts the door behind her.
Now out of sight from SCP-6448, agents inquire
at the victim’s address, and the victim
promptly complies.
Operatives instruct the victim to have possession
of all firearms and weapons on the premises
and to barricade herself inside a safe space
with one exit point.
The victim swiftly begins grabbing all available
weapons and throwing them inside a wardrobe.
It is at this time that there is a knock on
the front door.
The victim does not respond and continues
to hoard sharp objects from kitchen drawers.
The knocking becomes more violent as the handle
is jostled and shaken incessantly.
A voice on the other side repeats the phrase
“Hello, it is me.
Hello, let me in.”
in a calm manner as the door begins to shake.
The victim retreats to her wardrobe, armed
with a small firearm.
Upon sealing herself in the space, the knocking
ceases, and footsteps can be heard becoming
further away.
The sound of galloping is audible as the front
door caves in.
Hoof steps can now be heard inside the home.
The entity continues to repeat “Hello, it
is me.
Hello, let me in.”
as it searches the small building.
A bright light flashes overhead, seemingly
circling the house.
Eventually, the entity enters the victim’s
bedroom.
Through a small slit in the wardrobe door,
the victim can see a Cervus canadensis standing
on its hind legs and surveying the room.
Its movements are crooked and stiff, seeming
to struggle to stand in a bipedal fashion.
It slouches down to a quadrupedal crouch,
similar to the stance of an arachnid.
It inhales heavily, and its head locks on
the view of the wardrobe.
It is noted as possessing human eyes.
It scampers towards the subject and opens
the door.
A single gunshot is heard.
Responders found no trace of either SCP-6448
or the victim."
Containment of SCP-6448 is focused on the
investigation of any deer exhibiting anomalous
traits in and around the Appalachian area.
Any civilian sightings of SCP-6888 are to
be handled by Mobile Task Force Gamma-4, or
the "Green Stags".
Any possible deaths resulting from SCP-6448
will be blamed on hiking accidents, and any
reported sightings can be explained away with
Chronic Wasting Disease.
CWD, occasionally referred to as "zombie deer
disease" is a prion disease affecting members
of the Cervidae family.
Symptoms of the illness include loss of motor
function control and damage to decision making,
as well as gradual degradation of all mental
faculties.
It is one hundred percent fatal.
However, though the disease does exist, most
recorded cases of it in the Appalachian region
can actually be attributed to instances of
SCP-6448.
Any captured instances of SCP-6448 should
be transported to Site-44 for the Cryptozoology
Division's containment and study.
On November 29, 2019, they finally got their
chance to bring a Not Deer into custody.
The Green Stags were able to capture an instance
of SCP-6448 with help from MTF Nu-7, "Hammer
Down", and their heavy vehicles division,
as well as some experimental shock rifles.
One Not Deer was knocked unconscious in the
conflict, and its body was loaded onto an
armored helicopter and flown straight to Site-44
in Essex, England.
At the site, it was then placed in a reinforced
steel containment cell, and heavily sedated.
This entire process went off without a hitch.
As the entity began to regain consciousness,
Cryptozoology Specialist F. Ozz watched it
through a one-way glass window and attempted
to speak to it through the intercom.
"Greetings, SCP-6448," Researcher Ozz began.
At the sound of his voice, the creature jumped
to its feet, staring at the intercom.
"Can you understand me?
We've seen your genus speak English just fine
in the past."
The animal did not answer, but began licking
one of its legs and behaving as if it were
an ordinary deer.
Researcher Ozz sighed impatiently.
"Please, we know your secret."
The Not Deer stopped what it was doing, freezing
completely still as it listened to his words.
"Admittedly, it wasn't exactly well kept.
If you'd just look at yourself for more than
a few seconds, it is very clear that you're
not...normal."
At this, the creature, which had been facing
away from the window, swiveled its neck 180
degrees, breaking its own spine with an audible
crack.
It stared, unblinking, at the window and directly
at Researcher Ozz.
Ozz turned to the containment staff, suddenly
anxious.
"I thought you said this was one-way?"
The staff assured him that it was, and there
was no way the Not Deer could see him.
Still, its eyes were locked directly on his
face.
He shook off the sense of unease and continued
his line of questioning.
"Are you something imitating deer?
It is clear that, if so, you possess basic
anatomical knowledge of them, though details
are clearly faulty.
In fact, a better question would be...how?
If, in fact, you are not what you pretend
to be."
The Not Deer opened its mouth at this, revealing
unusually sharp teeth.
It moved its jaw as if attempting to speak,
but only a choking sound came out.
"Shall we move on?"
Ozz asked.
"What I'm more concerned with here is why
you take our people.
Is it a vendetta?
Spite?
Food?"
For the first time in the interview, the Not
Deer blinked.
It was an unnatural movement,
forced and deliberate,
like the creature was attempting to engage
in an ordinary behavior rather than actually
experiencing an involuntary impulse.
"Responding is mandatory," Researcher Ozz
prompted.
The creature did not react.
"If you will not comply," Ozz's tone grew
stern, frustrated.
"Maybe you'd like to see your brand new
containment
cell."
At last, the entity spoke.
"R-Rasaerch.
Research."
Its voice resembled a distorted version of
Ozz's.
"Research?
What kind of..."
Ozz wasn't able to finish his question.
"July 7, 1947," the creature said, before
ramming into the one-way glass and cracking
it.
As Ozz stumbled backward from the force, the
creature collapsed on the ground, seizing
and screaming as its abdomen.
"Get the Stags in here now!"
Ozz cried out, but it was too late.
A black mass of something shiny and tendriled
leaped out of the Not Deer, scuttling around
the cell before shattering the window and
leaving the empty shell of a deer behind.
The Site-44 Breach System activated and attempted
to initiate emergency containment protocols,
but the mysterious black mass escaped its
sector, made its way toward the main exit,
broke through the glass on the front exit
door, and vanished into the shrubbery outside.
The escaped anomaly could not be found and
recontained.
Ever since this incident, there have been
a record-breaking number of Chronic Wasting
Disease cases identified
in deer in the surrounding
area, as well as an unprecedented increase
in UFO reports.
Further research is currently ongoing, but
it is unknown whether we will ever truly know
what these creatures are.
Only one thing is for certain: they are definitely
not deer.